and cities from the first of a number of
these expected settlements and judgments
so senate bill 275 makes several
changes to the current law
one it updates
the census reference from
the 2010
census to the most recent census
this way we can distribute money based
on population changes
without having to reopen the statute
every time there's a new census the bill
also changes the appointment of one of
the members that member representing
county nursing homes to be appointed by
their association
instead of from the governor because no
appointment
and it's an important
member
three we
add prevention and school programs to
the list of programs eligible to apply
for the funding
and we also then add a school
superintendent to the
members of the commission
and finally the duties of this
commission are clarified to
explicitly include evidence-based
prevention efforts as an eligible use of
the money to mitigate opioid harm
and additionally the annual report looks
to collect measures of success
on the programs funded
to the extent that these measures are
available
mr james befetti from the department of
justice is here he can better answer
questions about the ongoing litigation
but i'm pleased to bring you this bill
thank you mr chair
thank you senator rosenwald and i
recognize representative weber for a
question
thank you and welcome home senator thank
you
it's uh
i i i was emailed last night and a
proposed amendment for this bill and i
wonder if you have been consulted about
any amendments
and if so if you have any opinion on
them
i
did see
an amendment
um
a couple of days ago by email
and
my plan was to bring that language
to the commission
we're meeting on monday next week so i
don't know if it's the same proposed
amendment but i've added that subject
matter to
our
thank you agenda
representative
shapiro
question please thank you mr chair thank
you for taking my question i'm not sure
that
of what the
previously spoken about amendment
involves but i know that um
the city of keene where i'm from
are concerned about the allocation
of funds for the
municipalities that originally went in
on the um
on these suits
and i guess there was another bill i
think it was house bill 1565
that would have changed the allocation
for from 15 to 40 percent
and i'm not i'm i'm not as knowledgeable
about this as i should be talking about
us but i guess my question is
is there any
room
as far as your concern to change the
allocation for the municipalities that
originally
went in on these suits
because they have invested a lot and
because they've also done a lot of
thinking ahead of time of what kind of
programming they would use the money for
thank you for the question mr befetti is
probably better suited to talk about
the specifics of
who's done what in litigation but i'd
say that
um to my way of thinking it's
not exactly correct to say these cities
only get 15
they get 15
it's not only cities it's
23 i think jurisdictions
they get 15
is immediately distributed
as the funds come in to the treasurer
but
any program
is eligible
to apply for
funding
of the balance of the 85 percent the
state is keeping
zero percent of the money
so if you hear that the state is keeping
85 that's really not accurate so um
we are setting up uh
rules and a process
for
how the commission would evaluate grant
applications
but any city any county any program
excuse me
is able to apply for
the entire 85 percent remaining funds
follow up um
thank you um i yes i underst i
understand that they're not um limited
to the 15 but
um
from your response i would i would just
guess that you're not in favor of
changing the percentage of allocation
as i said mr buffetti is better able to
give you the history of how that was
arrived at thank you thank you
further questions
representative gay
thank you mr chair thank you senator
um
i'm not familiar with this
program at all it's great news that
we're getting some money back from the
people who helped make this happen
uh but could you explain just in
layman's terms
uh
what this what is the implication of the
cities that actually
uh sued first
and that
from what i read it sounded like their
people were concerned they weren't gonna
get
they weren't going to get the same kind
of
funds that people who didn't participate
in the suit
mr maffetti will probably correct me
however my understanding is
a number of lawsuits were filed
but then they were consolidated
and perhaps after the filing
the department of justice
really took the lead
on these suits
because the local
the local litigation was consolidated
but again he can he can explain that
better
we are talking about
tens of millions of dollars
over the next 20 years
it's a lot of money
okay thank you
representative
uh thank you mr chairman
welcome senator nice to see you thank
you uh just a quick uh item i'm
wondering if it's a typo in on roman
numeral six it says on or before
november first 2020 the commissioner of
the department uh to submit an annual
report do we mean that to be 2022
um
thank you for the question no this is
current current law
and um this is an annual report
so the first one was due
then okay thank you senator
okay thank you very much senator thank
you
like to recognize uh representative judy
aaron if i
read the name correctly
now the
the end kind of faded that's what
good morning mr chairman and good
morning committee members it's great to
be here
my name for the record is representative
judy aaron i am the representative for
sullivan county district seven
representing the towns of akworth goshen
langdon lobster and washington in
sullivan county
and i was the support the the prime
sponsor of uh hb 1565
which sought to also make some changes
to these
opioid abatement
statutes
we were looking to
increase the amount of allocation
of the
proceeds from these litigations
to from 15 percent to 40 percent we had
negotiated down maybe to 30 percent
but i'm not seeking that kind of change
today
what i'm coming to you today with
and which i emailed you last night
uh is a suggested amendment to this sb
um to this this particular bill
presented by senator rosenwald which i
support
i
is is basically some housekeeping
changes and
as you hear this bill i'd like you to
consider making a few additional changes
to this statute
first and foremost
i'd like you to consider eliminating
what we call the population penalty
which is levied upon our counties
with regard to the 23 entities which
were the original litigants in these
opioid lawsuits
eight of our ten counties are penalized
now
by eliminating the population of any
municipality within that county
that were also litigants in the original
national opioid lawsuit
as a result
each county receives less money from the
settlement distributions if any
municipality within it joined in in the
litigation the fact is
that the counties and municipalities
have vastly different programs which
they offer
and which stand to be funded by these
distributions going forward
the county should not be penalized just
because a municipality within that
county decided to join in the original
national lawsuits
for example
sullivan county would be penalized the
population of claremont
yet sullivan county still serves the
people of claremont in their county
programs
the county opioid abatement programs
that they offer
so the population penalty isn't fair in
this respect and i have attached
language
which i
have passed out to you
which would
fix that
it would it would be an amendment to fix
that and that is shown
on the page that says suggested a minute
amendment to sb 275
i
put in
that paragraph
which which describes the distribution
according to a file the formula of the
following formula that the distribution
shall be calculated by multiplying the
settlement amount by the population
factor
and the allocation factor where the
population factor is derived by dividing
each qualifying counties and
municipalities population by the state's
total population and the allocation
factor is set at 15 percent it's 15
percent now so i'm not making any
changes to that and you can see on the
spreadsheet that i sent out also
i used the example of the mckinsey
settlement which was the first
settlement that came through
and you can see in column h
what the actual distribution was
and that actual distribution included
this population penalty
in column i
i show what the county would have
received
without the population penalty
in other words
if you look at solomon county
they would have received instead of
9565.87 thirteen thousand seven hundred
and seventy dollars and four cents
because in
the column i
i did not take out the population of
claremont
so i think this is important
um
and i'd be happy to write up the
amendment through ols to do this for you
um
i've also so i
did provide a spreadsheet that shows the
difference yes
is there an extra copy of the
spreadsheet so i can follow along please
oh yeah um
thank you representative merchant sorry
about that
so i've provided the spreadsheet which
shows the difference in allocation
distribution
of the settlement dollars for this
mckinsey settlement which should have
meant to the counties had the population
penalty not been in effect so again if
you compare columns h and i to see the
difference for some counties the
difference is quite meaningful because
the population penalty
which is shown in column g
is substantial for instance
stratford and hillsborough county suffer
a 49 percent population penalty because
of the municipalities in their counties
that decided to be a part of the
original national litigation
and you should also know that the 13
municipalities who were original
litigants represent
roughly 50 percent of the opioid problem
in our state
they recognized early on the problem
which is why they decided to join in on
the national litigation
and i must add too that if it wasn't for
these 23 entities participating in the
litigation new hampshire may not have
received anything from these lawsuits
additionally
i've also uh proposed some language
uh
well basically this the the language
that i'm proposing for this new the
allocation calculation
should be spelled out and clarified in
statute
and finally
i i
you you brought up the point before that
there was a no in in
rsa 126 a colon 84 6 which mentions
november 1st 2020
so what i've done is i've
i've
changed rsa 126
a
colon 84
uh
roman numeral 4 and roman numeral 6
needing to be changed to reflect annual
reporting and remove the 2020 year
mentioned in the current statute
so with that
i'd be happy to entertain any questions
about
what i'm proposing
i think the the um
okay we'll hold it there then
recognize representative weber sure
thank you mr chairman and thank you very
much for taking my question
uh without having been familiar with the
formula before
what i am wondering is why it is that
when when you
we already have the the 15 percent
that
has been taken out
what your formula does it seems to me is
double dipping on the cities because not
only does claremont continue to get the
dedicated funds for claremont but then
sullivan county also gets the funds that
would be allocated to claremont so
doesn't that
result in a double dip well some people
would suggest that that is the case but
it is not really the case because our
counties
um they still
include the citizens of say in sullivan
county of claremont in their
programs that they work that they do
and
so the the the programs that the
counties are offering are
way different
and different in scope and different in
how they operate than what a
municipality would offer
so
no they're not really double dipping
because they're doing different
functions follow-up
but if we're allocating the funds on the
basis of population we're counting the
population of the cities twice are we
not
under your formula
you could suggest that that's the case
but i would i would counter and say that
whether the the municipality
participated in the original lawsuit or
not
there still should be funding coming to
this to the county
to help them pay for the programs that
serve those people in those
municipalities
okay thank you representative kanark
mine is very much along the same line
not taking the attack of looking to see
if it's double dipping but instead since
lines 8 through 10 of the original bill
say the population of any
political subdivision so that would mean
both the municipality and the county
that receives funds shall not be
included in the population of the county
so if if they are getting it all it
means is they're going to keep it equal
is that not how you read lines 8 through
10 is that
it is simply going to be the population
of the county and it doesn't get counted
twice
which
lines eight through ten of the original
bill i'm sorry the bill as amended by
the senate not your amendment right okay
so the population of any political
subdivision which receives funds under
this section shall not be included in
the population of the county
well that that's again that's the
population penalty i'm talking about
that they are removing
the population of for example claremont
from sullivan county follow up and the
county gets punished for it
follow up but doesn't that only occur if
claremont
is already getting the funds i mean this
precisely what it says is that if
claremont gets the funds
that the county doesn't get their funds
and the other funds isn't that what it's
saying which is not a penalty it's not a
bonus
and i've been referring to the bill as
amended by the senate
thank you
i see it i see it as the the population
not being included
representative weber
and just so i'm clear about where we are
procedurally my understanding is that
your original bill
which
had
great consideration in another committee
has been referred for interim study is
that correct yes
but that had a change in the allocation
of increasing the amount of money coming
you know instead of 15
going to 30 or 40
but
a follow-up but isn't it true that that
that is the committee that deals with
the money issues and we are the
committee that deals with the health
issues is that not correct
well it's still a matter of policy of
how much money you want to
uh you know how how the money is
allocated
any further questions for the
representative representative
thank you mr chair
um
i'm looking at the columns and i know
there's different
bills we're talking about but under
column e and column f
they don't add up to the same ones 133
percent once 100
why is there such a delta
well because um in the
why would they both add up to 100
because
in in the column e
you are not including
in column e you are subtracting out the
municipalities
from
i'm sorry in in
column e you are not
including the population penalty you
will have the full population
of the um
of each county
and then you have the the population of
the
uh the municipalities
in column f
you would be removing say for instance
claremont's population from
uh sullivan county and so that's why
that comes out to 100 percent
the other would come out to 133 percent
because you have 33 percent
um
the 10 counties represents 100 of the
population of the state
and one more follow-up thank you mr
chair
so when i look at the column and so
forth what i'm hearing is the fact go
back to prior comment
that there's some double dipping going
on when counting the population twice
you can suggest that it is counting the
population twice but it is because the
counties programs are different than the
municipalities programs and the county
is still providing programs for members
of the municipalities that are included
in that county
okay representative gay
thank you and i'll be brief how much
did claremont this is just an example
because obviously several towns must
have gotten a settlement and that's why
they're being taken out of this where
can we see how much those towns got to
justify why they're being left out of
this settlement
i'm not sure i understand your question
well
for some reason the towns are being
penalized so i assume that means they
already got
a settlement
the if they did not this makes no sense
to penalize them but it just sounds like
for this double dipping concern
apparently the town's already got some
kind of settlement point of order mr
chair
point of order the language says clearly
on line nine receives funds under this
section it does not refer to any other
funds received under any other pro uh
program
we we're spending a lot of time on a mis
misreading of the bill
it says uh line nine funds under this
section so it's not talking about other
funds so we don't need to dwell on that
all right well we'll stipulate that we
have a difference of opinion on the
interpretation of this bill
representative aaron and what we want to
do is to hear as recommended by senator
rosenwald uh from mr buffet who can give
uh specific technical
updates for us
so if we could uh with your in
understanding we could move on
sure to that and we know this bill would
require additional work thank you so
thank you very much
like to recognize uh
mr buffett
oh in that case representative velma you
may approach the bench
everything's under appeal right now so
yes you can
thank you
representative susan elmi grafton 13
and um
i was the
co-sponsor of the motion which was
interim study which passed unanimously
in our committee
we spent a great deal of time on
on
and we went through a lot of
spreadsheets
i just wanted on to make clear some of
the reasons that we voted to interim
study this
on
first
on we're talking about 23 entities which
would get more money than anybody else
in the state because they signed up for
one of the lawsuits
on which mr befetti will probably be
talking about
on
those 23 or the 10 counties
which
would cover the whole state
and 13 municipalities 12 of which are
cities one of which
the one city that didn't sign on was
mine agreeing with what the commission
was doing
and
those um the rest of the
towns in the state
include
salem
and bedford and a number a large number
of other towns that are bigger than some
of the ones in the 20 in the 13
municipalities
we looked at
the death data
for the last
two and a half years couldn't get
get it since
the second half of last year
on and the deaths are occurring all over
the state
in very small places in very large
places the most of them are in
manchester uh
and and nashua because of the
populations and the population
concentration probably
but
that is one factor that what we would be
doing would be
putting
most of
on
more of the money originally it was over
50 percent of the money
uh in the hands of the litigants
that signed on to this particular
lawsuit
on and
less available
for
a statewide initiative
to try to control opioid
abuse
in this state
and
we felt
uh the policy part of that is yours but
the
uh the money part of it was ours
and we felt that it was more important
to do it from the state level
the other factor that was involved in
this is that
on
the commission
has been as you know it takes a long
time to get things through jail car
and if they're going to jail car right
now until they do
they have not made votes on discussions
they have had about where the money
would be first spent
and
we have heard
uh allegations that
uh one of the first priorities would be
that the money would go to the jails for
jail treatment because it's extremely
important
in this process it's one of the key
points where
where that starts opioid
overdose
but
on they haven't taken votes yet
and uh until then
this uh hype and and we also know that
there are quite a few towns that have
been
taking action within their towns about
drug overdose but are not among those 13
litigants
so on
we voted partly because
interim study because we don't know yet
we won't know until after they've taken
those votes which should be very soon
after jail car finally meets
uh on this
on
whether
the um
how the distributions
would be likely to
occur and you won't know either
until that happens
uh and then
in your policy position you could second
guess something but
that would end up
next year
and
on
the
and we felt that it's it's important
it's a lot of money but it's a lot of
money that when you divvy it up
among all
all of those places if you did it that
way
that uh
helps
if you do it
with the population penalty
you
help a little bit more places like
claremont and and manchester
uh but you
penalize
all the other towns
that
did not sign up for this lawsuit
all right representative bellamy then uh
your recommendation on the bill
on
well i
i think i looked at it i felt that the
bill was was very reasonable i
especially like the fact that they're
getting the county association to
appoint the county person
and uh
but
that's just my personal opinion so
you're in favor of the bill as presented
i'm in favor of the bill as president
okay thank you very much
i'd like to
recognize mr uh james buffetti
and if if you could uh
keep your
advisories as tight as possible i i will
uh so we can learn quick sure i i will
do my best um
thank you mr chairman members of the
committee my name is james buffetti i'm
an associate attorney general
i have been the the state's primary
litigator uh for opioid cases since 2015
um and these cases are in a variety of
stages but there is now settlement
monies that are coming to the state from
different settlements we also have a
one trial that is scheduled for
september in merrimack county superior
court against johnson and johnson
so i come in in support of the bill as
presented
uh we
are in opposition to the amendment as
proposed this morning by representative
aaron
um
and i can i'm happy to talk through the
issues
uh in terms of the amendment
um and we had a vigorous debate in ways
and means about this issue i think i
testified five times in front of the
committee
there is a reason why the current
statute uh counts population the way it
does
uh
representative aaron calls it a
population penalty it is not a
population penalty it is a protection
against double counting
and so you don't get to to you get 15 of
the funds to be distributed
to
those 23 subdivisions who
who filed lawsuits
and that's that's what you have 15 the
question is how do you distribute that
money fairly
and so if you don't deduct the
population from those cities in a county
that filed these lawsuits then you
double count them so for instance in
hillsborough county both manchester and
nashua filed lawsuits if you do not
deduct their populations then
hillsborough county essentially gets a
windfall and you don't get to a hundred
percent you don't get to
because there's just not enough money
there's no way that math works it just
doesn't work that way and let me just
say you know we've had a a lot of
discussion
about these 23 subdivisions
so let me explain to you as clearly as i
can exactly what they did
they hired outside contingency fee
council right these outside lawyers from
outside of new hampshire came in made a
pitch to them and said we can get you a
lot of money just sign on the dotted
line these law firms
are filed essentially generic
lawsuits in all of these counties and
these 13 cities and towns
those count those cases were all
filed
or removed to federal court
all of those federal court cases were
consolidated in a court in cleveland a
federal court called a multi-district
litigation court where those those cases
have stayed dormant for years
they have not litigated anything in
those cases they have not filed any
motions they have not done any
depositions they have not exchanged any
discovery they simply went there to die
and so
for for 23
of these subdivisions who who were
pitched something by these outside
counsel and
for them to get 40 percent of the money
under the under that proposal in hb 1565
made no sense to us because it excludes
all of those other cities and towns
those 200 or so cities and towns that
didn't
hire these outside lawyers
so
i you know i i drafted a lengthy
objection to hb 1565 that i gave to ways
and means i'm happy to leave a copy of
that with with the chair if that's of
help to anyone but it lays out exactly
what the objections to hb 1565 was by
the department of justice
i would say this the the current statute
is a good statute it's a good way of
dealing with this money it's a fair way
of dealing with this money
all of the money will be used for opioid
abatement all of it that was a first
principle and so now
85 of the money goes into this opioid
abatement trust fund a dedicated trust
fund that has to be used for abatement
purposes
and a commission which is a wide-ranging
commission made up of all sorts of
people county
city town
police fire
we will and i'm a member of the
commission we will
consider different proposals for how
best to spend the money in this state to
abate the crisis so that we stop people
from dying every day of opioid overdoses
which is what's happening right now and
so we should come together as a
community of a state to figure out the
best way to spend this money
have to have the best effect and this
should not be a fight over over trying
to get more money for certain for
certain subdivisions that simply hired
outside council and by the way this
outside council it's a national firm
right
we have a case against j and j
we're going to trial against j and j
so i contacted them and said
you should move to remand your cases out
of the mdl that cleveland court bring it
back to new hampshire and try it
their lawyer said to me we don't want to
do that because there's not enough money
in it for them not for the state for
them they they didn't feel it was worth
their while to to to actually have these
cases brought back for trial
so i mean it tells you that we're
dealing with a very different dynamic
here of outside counsel who by the way
are going to make millions of dollars
out of these settlements
these people are not going to be hurt
but
my objective is to bring the most money
we can into new hampshire as a state
with working with all of us county
cities towns figure out the best way to
spend it now somebody mentioned about
about spending the money for uh for
people who are incarcerated right
because one of the most effective ways
of dealing with opioid addiction is
through medication-assisted treatment
all right everybody that deals in this
field will tell you that and so the
jails are spending money
every day for m a t
i i'm only one member of the commission
but i have said at the commission
meetings and i'll say this publicly and
i will say to the commission
we should be funding mat
for every county that spends the money
we should encourage them to
to to distribute these drugs to people
in their custody who are suffering from
opioid use disorder we should uh we
should support the programs that they
have for people in the jail who are
struggling with substance use disorder
that is a good use of our money and so i
i think that we will get there but i'm
certainly going to be one voice saying
this is a good use of the money and we
should make a commitment that we will
take this money that comes in every year
and we will use it to to offset the cost
that the counties currently have for m a
t
thank you attorney befetti do we have
questions uh representative weber and
then representative gay
i have two if i may mr chairman the
first one was simply would you be
willing to email that memo that you
presented to ways and means to all of us
as well sure just so that we don't have
to use all that paper yes
thank you happy to do that because some
of us are drowning um and i and i can
just say and i'll put it in my email but
there was at the time that i that i
wrote the email that there were these
annual reports that are submitted by the
counties we talked about it so
sullivan county had had had submitted it
but i had not received it because it
went over to hhs and got lost somewhere
so i just want to make sure that that
sullivan county
has submitted a report and by the way
all of the reports
of all these counties are on a website
that hhs hhs has on their main page and
it has the opioid abatement trust fund
so you can find all those letters there
that show how counties are using the
money or what they've done with the
money they've received so far
follow-up
and my second question would be would
you agree with me that
the important thing to do with this
money is to distribute it according to
patient need rather than who filed first
yes
thank you representative gay
thank you thank you
um i'm still would like the
basic numbers of money that's already
going to the towns
and going because it's a
you know i hear the 30 and
well whatever percentages so it would
really be nice to understand
how that because to me the simple thing
would put all the money in a plot
divided by population and need and let's
treat the whole state i want to
understand the restrictions that the
that apparently this 40 going to the
ones who sued
number one how much did they cost so
that could be subtracted that could be
added back to whatever they are due
i just don't understand
how what money they already are getting
because they participated in the suit
how do you balance that out with even
distribution so i can send you in in
addition to the to the copy of the
letter i can send you a the copy of the
chat that shows how much money those 23
subdivisions got in the first settlement
we had a small settlement last year
um and there was approximately 414
thousand dollars that were distributed
to those 23 and i can show you the
amounts
that were given so for instance in
sullivan county if i may tony just send
the information that's fine and we'll do
it that way any further questions
representative merchant
i'd like to follow up thank you for
taking my question follow up on the
question asked by uh represent weber
it sounds like we have based upon
population of some determination but i
think the need is probably more critical
as far as the allocation is there any
way in which the commission is looking
at the need factor versus strictly the
population factor
well sure i think that that that's going
to be one of one of the basis for
for evaluating these grant applications
is going to be the need so that's one of
the first things in the rules in terms
of how we do it is going to be need
based
okay
i'll say representative knuck just a
quick one you mentioned the initial uh
settlement of 414 000 and you said you
sent us information on what the 23 got
but did that go to only those 23 or did
that go to the counties as well or was
it to go to all the political
subdivisions or was that unique to the
23. so it went to the 10 counties and 13
cities and towns who hired outside
contingency council thank you
okay thank you mr chairman thank you
attorney yep
like to recognize uh
ms kate frey
from new futures
good morning members of the committee my
name is
excuse me
kate frye i'm the vice president of
advocacy and new futures it's nice to be
back in this room um
i am in here to speak in support of
sb275 i will say right now i'm i am not
taking a position on the formula but i
would like to agree what's been said
about the um
ideal opportunity here is that we have
to understand that this money will go to
um opiate abatement and to
make up for
um just the dangerous situations we were
in when people were um
with the opiate epidemic and so i
applaud that whereas um we have an
alcohol fund where very little of that
money goes to actually um prevention
treatment and recovery mri you indicate
you have copies of written testimony
is that in your hand right now yeah yeah
you just distribute that and just give
the quick overview because
we need to stay on time
so i will be two minutes based on that
i'm in support of the bill especially
around um the aspect of the bill that
and um adds prevention programs for
funding for the opiate abatement trust
fund um we appreciate representative
senator rosenwald and representative
acton putting in this bill right now if
you look at the projects that can be
funded under the opiate abatement trust
fund it's outlined about recovery and
treatment and we really feel the full
continuum of care is necessary
when you talk about um
um uh opiate abatement um the damage
that was done and and what the trust
fund can go to so we are in support of
the bill but in particular the section
that adds prevention to um what the fund
can be used for
short and sweet
questions for ms frye
thank you very much thank you
like to uh recognize
catherine i believe it's heck i'm going
to make sure i say that correctly
and you have
as you requested two minutes yes sir so
thank you very much thank you sir
good morning committee members my name
is catherine heck i represent the new
hampshire municipal association and i
did not plan to comment today as we are
mostly following this legislation
however based on testimony and the
recent development of an amendment i
felt it prudent that i raised some
concerns
so i won't repeat any previous testimony
i'll be brief
we're not taking a firm position on the
bill as you know because we don't
support some members over others however
we and we agree that the counties have a
very different function and different
programs and municipalities would have
we have not seen the amendment
and we have been in contact with the 13
municipalities that originally signed in
to the original settlement which are
belmont berlin claremont concord dairy
dover franklin keene laconia londonderry
manchester nashua and rochester and
they would not like to see any change in
allocation
they already have programs in place to
treat educate and mitigate the ongoing
battle with this crisis
however communities that are not part of
the original sentiment based on the 2020
legislation might not have signed on
because they also have or will be
developing programs and agreed with the
allocations in currently in legislation
our members are concerned about any
change and formula and they would like
to see the original language stand
unless a further study and input could
be made possible and that's all i have
unless you have questions sir thank you
ms hack questions for ms heck
no we're clear thank you very much
and uh
the last person that we have signed up
is uh ms kate
is that her guy
oregon excuse me
new hampshire association of counties
and you have a a handout
oh good
and and uh two minutes to provide the
overview yes mr chairman thank you i
will be very brief uh the association of
counties does support senate bill 275
primarily because the nursing home
administrator position was left vacant
for nearly two years i was informed last
week that the governor finally did make
an appointment um to the commission for
the nursing home administrator however
we feel that the nursing homes
administers have an extremely important
voice on the study commission or on the
opioid trust fund i apologize and that
they uh deserve to have that position
filled so and we had someone ready to go
two years ago so
i will say just on the amendment we did
support house bill
primarily because counties are the only
entity that is statutorily required to
pay for mat funding in addition to the
state prison obviously
but just to give the committee an idea
on the cost it's a little over 2 million
for the 10 counties to run an m.a.t
program
i'm happy to take any questions
questions for ms hogan
no we're clear thank you very much
chair pearson you may exit the building
yes
thank you okay thank you very much uh
with no further comments i'll
call the end of the hearing relative to
senate bill 275
and we will
move now on to senate bill 3
and
recognize
senator rosenwald to introduce
senate bill 391
thank you mr chairman i'm cindy
rosenwald from senate district 13
nashua and
senate bill 391
will
ensure that the new secure psychiatric
unit that's going to be built on the
grounds of new hampshire hospital
will be managed and operated by the
department of health and human services
and not be privatized
some months ago um about probably six
months now
commissioner chevinette announced
publicly
that that
plan for operation of the as new spu
would be the case we would be
running it
operating it
with oversight by the department
but this bill will place the state's
responsibility
for the care of individuals not guilty
by reason of insanity incompetent to
stand trial or civilly committed into
statute so this will be the
legislature's
policy making opportunity
the bill does permit the department to
follow the model that's currently in
place
at new hampshire hospital
which is to contract with a private
entity
such as dartmouth hitchcock
for the provision of clinical services
this is what we are doing at this state
hospital
it's working well and it's what the
senate believes
we should be doing with the secure
psychiatric unit that we're
planning
thank you
i'd be happy to try and answer questions
representative kanark thank you very
much uh thank you senator rosenwald that
we we received a letter
um
from uh neil kirk uh who
had raised concerns that that we'd be
hiring very highly paid executives to
oversee the contractor's operation
but it sounds like what you're saying is
that
we'd be doing the same as you're already
doing that is to hire clinicians outside
and that the goal is that we would uh
the department would still
run it and manage it which they again
they already do with the with the
new hampshire hospital correct
that's correct and um just to to expand
on that as you know the state is
in the process of acquiring hampstead
hospital
and
we have approved through the fiscal
committee
six
administrative positions
one of which is
a ceo
i or ceo i believe
and we have appropriated something like
165 thousand dollars you will not find a
hospital
a private hospital
manager for anywhere close to that
amount of money i mean at dartmouth the
president makes over a million dollars
in nashua i think they make
three quarters of that so
the state does not
overpay
executives
any other questions representative mckay
and representative snow gets to turn on
representative k mckay's mike he never
can get this to work
there's a bad corner over there
electronically somehow
am i correct uh senator
my good friend
that uh there really will be two
secure psychiatric units
one under department of correction and
one under health and human services
is that an accurate statement there
seems to be some confusion about that
my understanding is that there will be
one
but that
the individuals who are currently
in the secure psych unit which is
presently located in the men's prison
would be moved to the new
facility when it
opens and if if i'm incorrect i'm sure
i'll be correct senator from the
oversight committee that's what i
understand too oh few
representative snow
it was my understanding
that several of the people that are in
the secure psychiatric unit that's now
operated at new hampshire prison are
incarcerated patients and that the
incarcerated patients could not be moved
to the new forensic hospital for
security reasons so that that operation
at least for the incarcerated patients
would continue
i guess under the department of
corrections and the reason for moving
towards the forensic hospital was
currently people who are
hot who are at new hampshire hospital
who become assaultive or commit other
offenses that require greater
control are now switched to the prison
even though they've never been to court
so that was one of the underlying
reasons for developing the forensic
hospital so people that are not
convicted of a crime do not get mixed in
with the prison population but those
that have already been convicted of a
prison
would remain at that same unit and it
would operate as a forensic unit and i
assume it would continue to be under the
department of corrections
am i wrong about that
uh i don't
representative i don't know what you've
been told by the department of
corrections
okay thank you
point of voter representative weber
is there perhaps somebody here from the
department of health and human services
who could tell us exactly what the
answer to that question is the cherubs
accepts your second
we're doing it
and would that person please come
forward thank you
thank you
good morning chairman pearson members of
the health and services elderly affairs
committee for the record my name is john
williams i'm the legislative director
for the department of health and
services and i'm very pleased to be
joined by
good morning my name is paula mattis i
am the director of medical and forensic
services for the new hampshire
department of corrections
and we had this exact same question
posed us when the bill was heard in in
the senate
and for purposes of just clarification
to revisit mckays and represent snow's
question
the population currently being served at
the new hampshire state prison currently
being served includes those who arrived
there by virtue of the criminal process
there was a crime committed they were
adjudicated and they ended up there and
that's just a very short um a version of
it you can hear the longer version by ms
mattis when i'm done with a high level
and then also the shorter version as
well is that there's a population that
were considered
or found to be forensically dangerous
and needed to be
transferred from the probate court
process which is different for an
involuntary admission to the state
hospital this is a very high level
summary of where things are currently
the direction that was provided by the
legislature in terms of policy for
developing a new secured psychiatric
facility was primarily focused on the
population that was coming into the
process through the probate court
through involuntary admissions
i am sure that ms mattis may be able to
further clarify but my understanding
would be that that would be the
population that would be served by the
new hospital that the legislature has
already set forth uh the bill in front
of you
deals with refining uh allowing us the
flexibility to doing the current process
of hiring our clinicians from dartmouth
hospital
through our contract with them to
provide those clinical services for the
hospital so that is very high level and
i hope that made sense to everybody and
if not this mattis will certainly make
much more sense than i
don't know about that yes representative
weber
before we go on so that we might do this
quickly
i think we all know how we got here the
question was simply
after the forensic hospital is built
will the people who were
incarcerated criminally continue to be
treated at
the prison or will those people go over
to the forensic hospital so i don't care
which one of you answers that that's the
question that i think we're trying to
get at
we will continue to provide inpatient
psychiatric services for those
incarcerated residents at the new
hampshire department of corrections
i would
i would ask going forward that any
questions from the committee and any
statements from those testifying address
to the bill exactly literally and while
the other information is valuable we are
on a tight schedule understood thank you
thank you
okay any other questions
okay representative cushman
thank you mr chairman
um
your question is of whom
i was going to ask mr williams um but i
don't even know if he's the one that i
should ask okay look at the bill is it
about the bill yes okay um so
it sounds like we're hearing an example
that the state would contract with
dartmouth hitchcock is is
how do we how is that contract going to
be determined is that going to go out to
bid
um
is that
okay it's going out to bid um
do we know if it's it's absolutely
necessary to hire administrators i know
that you said that they're not paid or
the last speaker said that they're not
paid you know an exorbitant amount
compared to the private sector um but is
it necessary to hire such administrative
staff as a ceo or is there um is it
similar to like where you hire a
staffing agency they don't send a co
they just send the clinicians you know
the nurses the the physicians and and
such is it necessary to hire
administrative staff the bill says the
department may do this
that's what we have that's what we're
voting on
i see no further questions relating is
this related to the bill we have before
us okay representative gay
hi we're all trying to speak and think
quickly
uh
the the immediate question was
does this contract
does this say that we are contracting
for a co and this just says it may
contract with private medical
organization for clinical services so
that opens a door to a big
interpretation personally i would think
you need a co if you have a certain
number of people not jermaine they'll we
are giving them permission to run a
hospital we'll trust how they do it
okay thank you
um
the chair would like to invite
representative leon into the room she is
next door babysitting
hearing what we're doing
and before we go forward to see if
there's no other questions on this and i
see none
then i will close the hearing on senate
bill 391 and open the exact session on
senate bill 391
representative
webber
i would move out to pass
representative weber moves ought to pass
somebody from
the other side
representative acton
second set
any
further discussion
it was
weber enacted weber and acton
representative not our opponent you're
in different places from where you well
this this seat was available well of
course it was it was yours
and we're friends oh i know anyway okay
having worked at new hampshire hospital
and interned there 25 years ago
the arrangement with dartmouth
works very well and if this psychiatric
facility is going to be built
very near there
is that true
the facility i believe will be attached
to the hospital
and
so i had heard private well
conversations that having
the same organization you know uh
oversee hospital staff you know so a
doctor could do a little bit in one
hospital and in the other they wouldn't
have to hire a whole new set of people
if this hospital had been built you know
20 miles away so i think it's a good
arrangement and i think we should pass
it thank you very much anyone else
seeing none and thank you so much
everybody would the clerk or one of them
called the roll
the motion is ought to pass on senate
bill 391 moved by representative weber
and seconded by representative acton
representative leon yes representative
mcmahon yes representative acton yes
representative gay
representative cushman yes
representative folsom yes representative
kelsey yes representative king yes
representative cofolt
is absent representative delemus
representative weber yes representative
mckay
representative snow yes representative
knurk yes representative soloway
representative cannon
representative nutter upham yes
representative shapiro
is
representative woods yes representative
merchant yes representative pearson yes
20 to nothing 22 zip and wood
representative weber representative
weber wood
donate to my campaign fund
would you like a reconsideration
that was a non-german amendment mr
chairman
but i would move consent
thank you
concludes the exec session on senate
bill 391 and uh thank you to
representative mcmahon for seat filling
and
everybody's going to get a turn today i
think
just a point about 275 which we heard a
minute ago
it is due out next week
and there's no point in executing it
because we've got all kinds of emails
coming our way to read it will be exact
next week just just let you know
it is an early bill
it is i believe the only early bill we
have today but we get a slew of them
next week
open the hearing on senate bill 229 an
act relative to pharmacist
administration of vaccines
and she's ready to go thank you
i'm happy to still be here
for the record cindy rosenwald from
senate district 13 in nashua
and i'm pleased to bring you senate bill
229.
um this bill is a request of the
pharmacists
and it will add certified pharmacy
technicians to the list of health care
professionals
who are authorized to administer flu
and covet vaccines under the direct
supervision of a licensed pharmacist
so this
is allowed under the current federal
emergency order it was also authorized
under governor sununu's emergency orders
but because the state's emergency orders
have expired the board of pharmacy
believes our statute overrides the still
existing federal emergency order
so the change to state law to allow this
group of individuals to give limited
vaccinations
is needed
representative merchant
i believe is a member of the board of
pharmacy if not its chair
and um
he probably could
speak
on
why
certain
certain vaccines
don't require
higher
levels of
licensed or certified professionals but
this is a request of pharmacists
and the board of pharmacy i believe
helped the senate with some language
changes
thank you mr chairman thank you senator
any questions for the senator
thank you so much senator the chair
recognizes
lindsay
uh is it lamberty or
you have nice handwriting i have bor i
have poor eyes seeing
thank you yes i am lindsay liberty i'm
actually a community pharmacist serving
on the board of pharmacy
um so i did bring copies and if you
would pass those out and you ask for
five to ten minutes i'll compromise and
give you five okay sounds good and
actually i know
all right um so as i said i am here on
the behalf of the board of pharmacy
we are encouraging you to vote to pass
senate bill 229 allowing our certified
technicians with proper training
and oversight to administer flu vaccines
in the state
our society continues to be in the midst
of a truly unprecedented time and we
have the tremendous privilege as
healthcare professionals
to provide access and support to our
patients as they are going through
some of the most vulnerable times
um with the rapid expansion of clinical
pharmacy services across the industry
it's ushered in a new era for pharmacy
certified pharmacy technicians for their
roles to advance
pursuant to the guidance under the prep
act as well as the emergency order
in new hampshire number 79 this allowed
pharmacy certified pharmacy technicians
to administer covet vaccines
and then with the passing of senate bill
they continued to allow that even once
those orders had expired
so the new hampshire board of pharmacy
voted unanimously to support senate bill
229 allowing our certified technicians
to expand to flu vaccines
this the certified technician does need
to be
certified to start so they do go through
a national recognized program take the
exam
continue with their education as well as
becoming certified to administer
vaccines which is the same program the
pharmacists go through
so let's see
will you take questions oh absolutely
any questions
representative cushman
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking my question
we had a similar bill last session um hb
572 that came through and it was passed
um
by the senate and the house and signed
by the governor can you just explain how
this bill is different from that one and
um so what changes are made between the
law that was passed by that bill and and
what makes this one necessary please yes
i believe that is a license yes
so that bill allowed licensed advanced
pharmacy technicians which is a new
um role that is still
kind of being rolled out in the state we
don't actually have any licensed
advanced pharmacy technicians yet um and
with the
that
licensee class had kind of started well
before covid hit
so with covid and justine how beneficial
having these technicians that are
certified so they're not licensed
advanced yet
uh certified being
able to give the coveted vaccines
it has just
helped pharmacy and community pharmacies
specifically
tremendously and as you know the cdc
recommends getting your covet shot or
booster along with your flu shot so a
lot of times it would cause confusion
when they were in the room getting their
covered vaccine
by a technician and then all of a sudden
they say oh no i want my flu shot and
they go hold on now i need to go get the
pharmacist
and um all the clinical
oversight is done by the pharmacist
we've checked
you know their consent form their health
anything is done and then we're
basically handing over the active
administration
to the certified technician
so i think especially come the fall this
will really alleviate stresses in the
pharmacy
any other questions
representative nutter upham
thank you for taking my question a quick
question who else can administer
shots um
lnas are
like nurses
um i just wanted i wondered who else so
with much less training than probably
your pharmacists have
what's my point i don't know yeah i know
um just from myself being you know going
to a clinton clinic um pretty much
anyone the medical assistants the
lnas the nurses
have been giving them as far as flu you
know i don't know the others right um in
the pharmacy so far we have pharmacists
and interns giving them
um interns can give
pretty much any of the ones that
pharmacists can as well
so okay thank you very much
representative cushman thank you mr
chairman so um
so we're trying to fix the fact that
they they couldn't um administer flu
shots but they had a narrow means of
administering coveted vaccines under rsa
318 colon 16-f which are repealing in
line 16 of this bill
that that
section of law required
particular conditions that would permit
them to administer coveted vaccines such
as the the vaccination is ordered by the
supervising pharmacist the supervising
pharmacist was ready readily and
immediately available um
that the cova vaccine was fda authorized
or fda licensed that the vaccine was
ordered and administered according to
the advisory committee on immunization
practices recommendations
that the registered you know there's a
list of of um things in place to make
sure that they're administered safely um
that proper training is in place and you
know that it meets some certain
standards um before it can be
administered
is there can you um speak to why you're
repealing that that that sect or why the
sponsor
and why you guys support repealing that
section
so yes
most
the
most basic answer is so that we can
include flu vaccines because that
strictly prohibits them from doing
anything more than the covet
again the certified technicians
and certainly if approved the board of
pharmacy will
you know formulate rules around just as
we have for pharmacists
around administering vaccinations
um
one follow-up
so i mean without repealing the section
though they could still administer the
flu shots with just the the addition in
section one of adding certified pharmacy
technicians um there's no need to repeal
this section if that's the only reason
and and i you know i have some
discomfort with taking it out of statute
and just leaving it up to rules
um
and and i i do have another you know
my follow-up is
um i noticed that this also takes out
the requirement to
um
report adverse event events
to the vares
database that was in the original build
that was passed so that that section
miss sheriff i mean
is this jermaine specifically to what
she just asked because you've got a few
heads it really is oh then absolutely go
for it okay
if you go back and look at
the rsa 318
16b all the things that you're referring
to representative cushman are in that
statute as well
so when the repeal 318
f
which is redundant to 318 b
we're still maintaining the same
requirements in 318b that were 318f
yeah and so what i'll take a look okay
take a look if you don't thank you thank
you and now
with his mic on and ready to go
representative snow
so i know i'm the leader well
i'm in charge of a microphone and i'm
the least competent microphone operator
in the entire world but you did well
this time i did i did well i just want
to confirm i think she answered my
question
this bill would
allow the
uh what is
the new pharmacy technician to only do
covert and influenza nothing else and
i'm assuming also that this technician
would never be giving shots to somebody
under the age of 18. is that correct
no
this would
yes allow only flu and covet
but it would be
um
below
two ages under 18.
it does say
follow up
yes it does say at the end it says
which have been approved
to individuals
18 years of age or older as ordered by
the immunizing pharmacy
oh okay but i am sorry i i thought that
had been
is that
is that correct
representative merchant
um thank you mr chair and thank you snow
basically the way the statue is written
they are only
allowed to give to the general public
the flu vaccine and covet vaccine
any other vaccine has to be done by
somebody 18 and older the reality is
this and talking to this
is the fact that children under the age
of 18 qualify for the universal
immunization program vaccine program so
when you talk to community pharmacies
they do not participate in that program
so even though a law allows them to do
it the reality is they can't because
they don't get the vaccine from the
state
so that's just a clarification point on
that as well
so representative weber
wave off
any other questions
seeing none
and seeing no further questions on this
thank you so much
and um
this closes the hearing on senate bill
229 i know there were some
questions earlier representative cushman
um
uh are you good to go
do you want to write amendments or
uh i may be interested in well we're
going to we're going to go to an exec so
it's got to be a you really do you want
that fast okay so no okay i do have an
amendment to submit to the committee to
this bill yes do you have it with you
yes
well then we will need to open an exact
session
right i think we closed 229 if we didn't
we just did
mr careful well he's distributing can i
clarify uh for representing snow that
question
just when he's distributing oh well
actually we're not in anything so let's
open
the exec session on senate bill 229
representative canarch yes the language
that's already currently in statute
below is the issue about 18 and under
and that is only for the uh
for the
diseases listed in line seven through uh
nine
the point is that the
phraseology in line five to the general
public has to do again with only the flu
and the covenant
so the point is it is to the general
public which would be a fifteen-year-old
for covet for example or for flu because
they do get it there but the other ones
are still for only over 18. it was
what representing merchants said is
correct but i just want to make it a
little easier that the statutory
information this breaks into the two
sets of immunizations thank you
uh we do have an amendment coming around
i don't have an amendment
and it is amendment
1312h to senate bill 229
and representative merchant if you would
like to
introduce your amendment
i should be careful how i say this
because it's really kind of a
housekeeping
you know and our history with
housekeeping has not been the last time
that led to some really good stuff sure
did so so what i have before you is the
amendment
which is amendment 2022
13 12 h
and
why i'm amending it is if you look at
the current bill
under the pharmacy intern in line three
which goes into line four refers to rsa
318 b 15b
and also licensed advanced pharmacy
technician under rsa
318-15c
however when you talk about the
certified technician directly with the
board there's no reference to an rsa so
all this does is reference it back to
the rsa which is 318.
um
b
sorry 38 3 18 15 a so we're being
consistent throughout the the bill the
statute that we're anchoring everything
back to on our side
would you like to move your amendment
please i would like to
you may ask a question representative
weber
i want to be sure i understand what this
is doing because it looks to me like
uh
section one as inserted by section one
of the bill
are you not replacing all of section one
of the bill by that language and
therefore you're losing a great deal of
the content
that's a good question representative
i think you're going to lose a great
deal of content if you pass this as it
is
so much for housekeeping
wow uh representative kanark i had the
same question at first i thought it
replaced all of them but since it says
only the part that is the 318
scott 16 be
roman 1 as inserted by section 1 it only
takes the lines 13 through 15.
so it does it might was my worry is it
replaced all of section 1 but it says
right the the the 3 18 16 be called
roman 1 as inserted by section 1. so i
think it's okay okay
okay agree this
representative weber
because you i wouldn't have drafted it
that way but okay
representative those who know the
subject area better or comfortable with
it all differ we have not a motion
before the floor we're clarifying to see
whether this motion for the amendment
should be put
so
okay
i want to point out that i'm not
clarified yet uh on the insertion of
the reference to reporting to bears
and when
when you gave uh the explanation of
duplication between f and
whatever the other one is
i i want to make sure before i vote on
this i want to make sure that it does
include the two points that
uh representative cushman
pointed out if mr fma yes uh
representative merchant this is under
16b
if you look at the number seven it says
submit reports of any vaccine adverse
reactions following vaccinations to the
cdc
first via theirs
okay so we're retaining
retaining that correct
okay
and as far as looking for the issue of
um training and so forth it's also if
you look at
that section
we're looking for it
two three four five six and seven remain
representative cushman
thank you mr chairman um
so
there is some that's repetitive between
that section that um section two of the
bill seeks to repeal um it's uh rsa 318
colon 16f but there are some pieces of
it that are not in in
318 b
um including that the certified pharmacy
technician shall complete um
cpr
that the supervising pharmacist shall
comply with all record-keeping and
reporting requirements that the
supervising pharmacist shall be
responsible for complying with
requirements related to reporting
adverse events
that they shall review the vaccine
registry or other vaccination records
before ordering
the registered or certified pharmacy
technician to administer the vaccination
that the supervising pharmacist shall
comply with any applicable requirements
or conditions of use as set forth in the
cdc's copen 19 vaccination provider
agreement and any other federal
requirements that apply to
administration of the vaccine that the
vaccine is fda authorized or licensed
that it's ordered you know there's
there's a couple of things that are in
318 16f that we will lose that were
there to protect the consumers of these
products
knowing that they were
new and
experimental so
especially the you know the cpr
and making sure that there's no
duplication um
i think those were important
um guidelines you know
and i i i would rather see
i mean i have no issue with the bill
besides section two that repeals that
part really um there is still the verse
um requirement because that's in section
one
uh section roman numeral one of 16b but
but with section
two repealing um these safeguards that
you know i can't support the bill
representative leon
thank you mr chairman um i i do
understand that as a newer vaccine it
may make sense to have a lot more of
these i'm curious if we would look at
putting a sunset provision onto that to
not repeal it now or repeal it two years
out or three or four years out if that
might be a way to prevent it from
needing to come before the committees
again but still allow those protections
for what
is a better understood but truly still
new vaccine so that we can
so that we can keep that for now
and then phase it out over time
not sure if that would be something that
would address that concern
yeah i think that would be definitely
meeting the issue in the middle i think
that you know that would be appropriate
after some time
um i also just have concerns about these
vaccines being administered to children
under 18 i don't know i don't i'm not
particularly comfortable with that
exception i know that's not the content
of this bill right now um but i i think
it's something important to think about
if we're doing an amendment
so it seems to me we are going to be
preparing some amendments to this
we are in an executive session i've not
called for any motions from the floor
that's where we are in this
representative weber
well it's up to you mr chair as to
whether we continue with the executive
session or just close the executive
session and let people go and get
whatever amendments they want to get
that is what i'm about to do thank you
and watch me do it
this closes the exact session on 229 it
is
due out the door by the end of the month
it is not an early bill and we will kick
it down the road to
two weeks from today and take a look at
the amendments now
i grouped all of senator rosenwald's
bills
thank you one great time senator pres
prentice is next week so thank you
open the now open the hearing on
senate bill 454 and the chair calls on
senator rosenwald
thank you mr chairman cindy rosenwald
from senate district 13
in nashua
and i am pleased to bring before you
sena pill
454 this is a study committee bill
and its purpose is to study the
information collected by the division of
vital records
when a woman gives birth in new
hampshire
as you know
vital records is part of the secretary
of state's office and new hampshire is
the only state
that does not house vital records in the
department of health and human services
we did
up until 2003
and
in that year it was moved to the
department of state as part of the
budget trailer bill
i asked senate research to see if they
could find out the reasons
for moving um
for moving this division
out of health and human services which
49 other states plus the district of
columbia do
they could only point to one sentence in
the trailer bill
that said it was to consolidate vital
records with other records maintained by
the state
so we really don't have any records of
discussion
surrounding the impact of moving these
records
with some extremely private information
in them
at the hearing on house bill 2 and that
back then
the
aclu did mention they had some privacy
concerns
i would also point out that the move
from
health and human services to the
department of state
was made before the hipaa privacy rule
was enacted
with its standards and guidelines and
stiff
fines for
violations
so the department of health and human
services is covered by hipaa but the
department of state is not covered by
hip
every birth in new hampshire is recorded
by the secretary of state
and they issue a birth certificate
this includes details such as when and
where the birth occurred the name of the
baby
who the parents are and this makes
complete sense to be housed in the
department of state
however much more information is
collected from the hospital
or birthing center
and the mother
and is transmitted to the secretary of
state although it is only used
in eventually de-identified form by the
division of public health which
is in dhhs
public health regularly de-identifies
protected health information
for important projects for example
tracking low birth weight babies covered
by medicaid maternal substance abuse
issues the department of state does not
use this information although they
maintain it in totally identified form
so the
information that is collected by the
secretary of state from hospitals and
mothers
is done on a worksheet i am not going to
hand out the worksheet because
the vital records division doesn't
actually make it public
but it's covered in rsa 5
c colon 19
and i'd be happy to share the worksheet
privately
with
anyone on this committee but out of
respect for vital records i'm not going
to distribute
this worksheet so it doesn't become part
of the bill's record
mothers are asked however to fill out a
form which is transmitted to the
secretary of state
she is required
under rsa 5c to provide her medical
record number
her height
her weight
both before she got pregnant
and at the time of delivery
whether she drank alcohol while she was
pregnant and how much
whether she smoked before and during
pregnancy and how much she smoked she is
not given the opportunity to opt out of
answering these personal questions it is
required by statute and she has warned
on the form that if she lies it is a
class b felony
in addition to this
extremely personal information that we
require women to tell the secretary of
state
the facility where the birth takes place
is also sending confidential health
information there including the date of
the woman's last period
the number of previous live births the
number of previous pregnancy losses
whether she is breastfeeding
what medical procedure she had
during childbirth her medical conditions
and health risks and whether she was
using drugs
i don't know about you
but i am extremely
uncomfortable with the idea of all this
private medical information being held
by the secretary of state
they do
not use it
and they certainly shouldn't
they state that they have strict
confidentiality rules and i'm sure
that's the case but they are not covered
by hipaa so they are not
subject to the really very stiff fines
that can be
levied federally and enforced by the
attorney general of the states
and as we know breaches can and do occur
even in new hampshire and once sensitive
information is exposed it's very hard to
undo it
so i believe and the senate believes we
need to take a good long look
at what's being collected
and where it goes there are options
before us
we could move vital records back to dhhs
and then we'd be like all other states
we could split up this birth information
and have the hospitals transmit the
information that becomes their part of
the birth certificate
to the department of state
and
all of the public health and medical
information could be transmitted
directly to dhhs
we could leave everything it the way it
is
and make the health information sections
uh
optional or voluntary for the for the
mother to release
but i don't believe we should do nothing
and all of the options that i just
mentioned have both pros and cons
both on policy but also cost so
i think before we should act we should
be prudent and and take a look at our
options over the summer and the fall and
that's why i'm before you today with the
study committee thank you mr chair
i
i hardly agree
with what you've said
however
i have a message from the speaker's
office
who wants this bill killed
not on its merits
but we've run pretty much running out of
people to put on study committees
and i know because i work with the
speaker's office not just for health and
human services issues but many other
issues and believe me
it is increasingly increasingly
difficult what i've suggested to a few
other people
with bills not just before this
committee but others
is
someone and usually it's this prime
sponsor of the bill
could pull together an ad hoc group of
people over the summer and do much the
same thing
and
[Music]
therefore submit an lsr in the fall
with the conclusions that group has come
up with so what we would wind up having
next year is a bill
that is the message i'm the messenger of
it
only was that if
um i heard thee would you believe in
your question that wasn't a question
here's what i would say about that i did
consider it but
i think any bill that makes any change
suggested to how state government
operates is likely to have
opposition from one department or
another
and if it has not had the gravitas of an
official act of the legislature to
compel
their
input
i think it is
uh
easier to
argue against and kill an eventual an
eventual bill i know what i would do
with this
information but i'm only one of 424
people
and that as you know
sir the senate is always reluctant to
studies
particularly
in the second year
but this was a a voice vote
and um it was unanimous out of a
committee it was a voice vote it's a
bipartisan bill
and
i think it's
worth acting
with the gravitas of the legislature
senator i anticipated your response and
already delivered it to the speaker's
office
and
i'm just the ping-pong ball in the game
and there it is representative weber
i'm still constrained by the questions
so would you believe representative
rosenwald that i came in
here today fully prepared to vote
against this bill
but
that your explanation of the privacy
considerations and i had no idea of the
extent
of the worksheet because of course
nobody can see the worksheet because
it's apparently a private worksheet
it seems to me that the extent of the
invasion
of
private
personal
information which we have a
constitutional amendment saying we're
going to preserve and be very careful
about
really changes my mind about what to do
with this bill and
had you brought a bill to
change the system i probably would have
voted for that too but
would you believe that i now am
more than willing to change my vote to
pass this
no matter what the speaker wants because
i think it's a really important thing to
be working on
would you believe it's easy for the
speaker to want it i'm the one that has
to go do the recruiting
anybody else yes representative gay
thank you would you believe the speaker
might be amenable if three of us
volunteered to be contribute
wow that is i would believe i'll fall in
good work that this committee does
gosh
yes representative weber
would you believe that my other
suggestion was to appoint three senators
and one house rep
i
i have another study committee bill in a
different different
house committee now and the senate
already took off the second senator that
i had proposed
in that bill but there are fewer of us i
i mean really in all seriousness
um i
think that if our constituents really
thought about this
they would be
um
very supportive of doing a study in my
own family
i have a seven-month-old grandson who
was born in dover
and his parents are both
lawyers and both have
experience in the criminal system
and even they were afraid to not fill
out this incredibly
intrusive form
because they were threatened with seven
years in prison
for lying about
how much my daughter-in-law weighed
before she even got pregnant
senator would you believe that in the
oversight committee that i chaired not
only are you president but two other
senators so there is precedence for
three senators but well let's just leave
it with oversight um just to
hume of the chair um
other other members of this committee
who would be interested in being on this
making my um task good thank you
uh so
and i have volunteered to be
the senator
hey they're getting the band back
together i'm really interested in yes
all right any other questions of the
senator
if anyone wants to see the the worksheet
i have it
hidden in my file with me
okay this ends the uh hearing on senate
bill 454 and i'm going to step out on a
limb here and exact
senate bill
454 and the chair is
looking for i'll cross out what i had
written here
and put uh
representative folsom moves
ought to pass
made
and who is this representative weber
any further discussion
see this is why we're the best committee
in the house you know this look at this
all comes together
any further discussion
nope okay seeing none the chair when
ready make
call the roll the motion is uh
senate bill 454
and on a pass made by representative
folsom and seconded by representative
weber may call the roll representative
leon yes representative mcmahon yes
representative acton yes representative
gay
representative cushman yes
representative folsom yes representative
kelsey
representative king yes representative
cofoult yes representative delemus
representative weber
representative mckay
representative snow yes representative
knurk yes representative soloway
representative cannon yes representative
nutter upham yes representative shapiro
yes representative woods yes
representative merchant yes
representative pearson yes and the
question before the chair is show up
make a motion to put it on consent thank
you you don't have to make a motion well
you can just chest any objection
shouldn't be okay consent blurb to be
written by folsom thank you very much
it is a matter of some regret for me
that
my mother
had made back in the days when she had a
two pack habit and a two martini habit
and had she not i might have actually
been a contender and had a brain
this
action by your mother will be an outlier
and not a model because you've turned
out well
and good
that ends the
exact session on
senate bill 454
and we now have won
281 and the chair recognizes senator
gannon
welcome to the best committee in the
house
you well i keep saying it
keep it going
simple not
don't say technology is not simple for
me though
but uh good to be here thank you
representative pearson um 281
um
it's sort of my pet bill for the year i
shouldn't say that because i might screw
it up but
um
i was at a nursing home a couple years
ago um my mom had broken her neck it was
a long slow decline she was 92 had a
great life though
but um so i got a call from the facility
i was at and we're looking for
longer-term care all americans said we
have a bed there's like 17 other people
want this then it's like the real estate
world
so i went there right away and they said
here's a 50-page contract
i'm an attorney i should know better but
i they said you know it'll be gone by
the morning if you don't sign so i
signed um didn't read a thing just get
my mom in here it's the best place in
the world to put her nothing right and
it was a great facility for my mother
all-american in london derrick did a
great job nothing but phenomenal things
to say about the staff
did wonderful things
so six months nine months pass my mom
passed away again great life long life
no sadness there um
and i went to
we had it was like middle of june and
they said to me
okay we're going to keep
you know i emptied the room out a couple
days later and they said we're going to
keep the last two weeks in june and then
the next full month
and i said well it's about 12 000 a
month and
a couple weeks we're probably looking at
eighteen thousand dollars and they're
like well you signed a thing we have a
30 days we start the 30 days
two weeks after
you know you're finishing a month so
we're not going to use june as the end
month so
we were going to lose it was six weeks
it was a lot of money most people in new
hampshire die with about 30 35 000 if
they're lucky so it's a significant
amount of money when they take 18 you're
paying for a funeral uh everything that
goes along with that and um taking care
of it
whatever there's not much money left for
most people and
so
i was fortunate enough to be in a
position that i could
probably put more pressure than most
people could and i got a little of it
back
but it was a very unfair thing and did i
sign it yes i did but they're in a very
strong bargaining position you walk in
and there's no beds available and so
should i have read every word and maybe
negotiated that contract i probably
should have but most people are
certainly not even in my position that
they would have the background to even
read the contract
so
they were going to keep 18 000. i think
in the end i settled when i got like six
back
but most people are not they're going to
so would say 30 days and it was
they also were enforcing me two extra
weeks so i thought this was very unfair
and i did not want other people falling
after me my parents are gone but
i'm getting up there in age my kids will
deal with it your kids will deal with it
we all every single family in new
hampshire is dealing with this and then
by the thousands and thousands every
year
so right now it's at 30 days
again i was in a situation where they
tried to tack on two additional weeks
whether or not they had a right to do
that that's one thing so i looked at the
law the law says 30 days from date of
death and um i don't like taxing dead
people especially because there's no
weight at these facilities it isn't like
they're going to have a 30-day period
they can't do it
you leave you take your
few possessions and they're very meager
at most of these nursing homes at the
very end are facilities
and so from the date that you take the
last piece of furniture out you have
they have 10 days
and that's they probably can find
someone in two or three days paint the
room put a new carpet in and that's
about it so none of the facilities are
complaining that the
10-day period is a
burden on them or anything it's a very
fair time period in case you maybe they
don't have someone to move right in um
maybe the room maybe somebody really
damaged the room and just wall damaged i
can understand that you got time to fix
the room so giving them time
a 10-day period which all the nursing
homes seem to agree as a fair period of
time
so we're cutting back um most nursing
homes we'll say they're in the vicinity
of 12 000 a month
so if you go from 30 days down to 10
you're giving every family in new
hampshire has to deal with this 8 000
more
to deal with their family affairs
we got to move along will you take
questions i will so this seemed very
good my only one thing there is a very
good a lobbyist who's going to testify
after me with an amendment to move it
from 10 to 15 because in new england
their nursing home groups have tend to
have a 15 day period
new hampshire's new hampshire
if it's a little more paperwork for the
nursing homes to make it 10 days it's a
2 000 are you okay with this amendment i
am not because it's gonna take two
thousand dollars out of every new
hampshire family that has to deal with
the death
so i would rather it stay ten days is 15
better than 30 sure it is
but when i have a bill that everyone
thinks is good at ten days
i know it may be in the financial
interest of the nursing homes to keep
another two thousand of your money i
don't think it's fair
thank you representative gay
after having dealt with this with two
parents um i would like to specify
be more specific in the date how much
you owe or how many days you're charged
for because it says i i love this bill i
just want to clarify
that uh with the day of death
to me
10 days after that ought to be enough 10
days after you empty the room
which can be that day
this is kind of just says the month in
which the resident died shall be
considered the last month of residency
that sounds like you would have to pay
for that entire month is there any way
to say you pay pro rated up to 10 days
after you clear the room the attorneys
who have looked at this
told me that it means 10 days so the 10
days would be but it would be after so
if you left a ton of furniture and the
nurse you know you really occupied that
room and you painted murals and did it
and takes them
we're giving them time to clear it up
but it'd be so if you died on a monday
your family had the stuff cleared out on
thursday it would be 10 days totaling
from that that thursday when you had
your furniture gone could we make
spell that out because right now it just
says you're obligated for the last month
there's nothing about pro rating it
almost sounds like you could stretch it
and say oh you paid to the whole month
and then you have to pay for another 10.
make it a question thank you
representative
kanark uh yes just a kind of quick
question when this
on uh line four it says for which
residents are paying out of pocket
and i was curious why this would not
also apply to residents covered by their
medicaid or insurance or is that are
they covered by different statutes
i don't think it's different statutes i
was only concerned with your personal
money i wasn't really concerned with the
government medicaid medicare so i could
see where that could apply though um and
as to your question
representative gay i think it's i don't
have that a numbered script in front of
me i just
yeah i don't have lines on my thing but
where it says um
the nursing home assisted facility shall
be entitled to rent and fees for not
more than 10 days from the date of the
resident's death provided that the
room's clear i think that makes it clear
that it's you get the date of death and
then however much time to clear i don't
think it needs to be more specific but
if this committee does i'd entertain
whatever you thought made it more clear
representative folsom that's gannon okay
um thank you in response a bit thank you
for taking my question um senator um
where it says or other responsible party
at the end
does that help include the medicaid
medicare
no okay
just wanted to
i don't think so that's just the
material anybody else with a question
for the senator seeing
none um thank you and the chair
recognizes brendan williams from the new
hampshire healthcare association
yes thank you
for your bill
thank you mr chairman honorable members
of the committee for the record i'm
brendan williams i'm the president of
the new hampshire health care
association i'm not the very good
lobbyist that uh senator gannon
referenced
however i do think that this is a very
good bill
we are
seeking a change
we think that the bill was
improved
in the senate
to provide for the 10-day period
we would seek to make that a 15-day
period
and let me back up and just say that
we represent various types of facilities
we represent
uh most of the state's private nursing
homes with a few exceptions a county
nursing home a pediatric care facility
uh continuing care retirement
communities and also assisted living
facilities
the idea of not charging beyond a
resident's death is the norm in nursing
homes that wouldn't change the status
quo even the 10-day period really
wouldn't be necessary for nursing homes
with respect to assisted living assisted
living is more
analogous to living in a residential
setting clearly by its definition
more analogous to living in say an
apartment
the idea that you could somehow
turn an assisted living residence in
just a couple of days just simply isn't
the case particularly now
at a time of an acute staffing shortfall
throughout our long-term care system
prior to the pandemic
there were over 400 000 more employees
working for
nursing homes and assisted living
facilities in our country than there are
today
and so
staffing has become very very
challenging and
facilities assisted living facilities
are budgeting in advance
when they have a resident in order to
meet that resident's needs
and uh because the
setting of an assisted living facility
is more residential
it's not analogous to say a hospital
room which a nursing home room might be
deemed analogous to
it is something more than that so
we think making it 15 days would uh be
similar to what connecticut does
connecticut is the only other new
england state
with this type of good consumer
protection and we would just simply
respectfully suggest that
we not go any further than
connecticut in establishing this sort of
consumer protection because we do have
providers that do uh business in other
states uh finally i would say that there
was a question about uh the second
sentence
uh the month in which the resident
passes shall be considered i would
respectfully suggest that that sentence
just simply be struck because i think it
creates a bit of ambiguity and i think
that the rest of the
language in the bill is clear on its
face and with that i would happily take
any questions
yes sir thank you for coming and
have you contacted any
member of this committee to prepare an
amendment such as you advocate
i know that uh our lobbyist has shared
an email with you uh mr chairman uh with
respect to the language of the amendment
and has spoken to the
co-sponsors of the legislation regarding
the idea of an amendment
we know that senator gannon has a
difference of opinion which i certainly
respect
with your lead mr chairman i think
representative gay has a question
oh yes uh representative gay the uh
sentence set begins on line five and
goes to line six uh beginning the month
i think that that should be str stricken
because i i don't think it adds anything
to the bill and it seems to create a
little bit of ambiguity i think the bill
itself is very clear on its face in
terms of what it's trying to accomplish
without that sentence
representative merchant
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question what's the
vacancy rate right now for nursing home
or assisted living facility in new
hampshire
well the vacancy rate in nursing homes
is pretty appalling i think that we're
probably at a and i have to look at the
latest data reported to the federal
government we're probably at a 75
occupancy rate in nursing homes uh prior
to the pandemic we were in excess of 85
percent uh probably and uh so we were
actually
uh
pretty full uh prior to the pandemic
right now the problem in nursing homes
is not
a lack of people willing to move into
the facilities it's a lack of staff
to take in admissions and so the state
as you're aware
has entered into contracts with some
nursing homes in order to provide
extra staffing
in order to relieve that pressure upon
the hospitals but
that's a admirable uh
endeavor on the part of the state but
it's a piecemeal approach uh facilities
really just can't admit now in many
cases
the other part of the question was
assisted living facilities i think
assisted living facilities are in better
shape for the most part assisted living
facilities and this kind of gets to a
question too that was asked
typically in our state do not take
medicaid
medicare does not pay for
assisted living care hardly pays for
nursing home care and so
uh i think assisted living facilities
are doing better however again you know
if you look at the the national data
where you know over 400 000 fewer
workers now
are serving uh residential care in
nursing homes uh the federal government
lumps those two things together
i would say probably three-fifths of the
losses in nursing homes but two-fifths
would be in assisted living facilities
so
everyone's seeing the consequences of
the pandemic when it comes to their
staffing
representative canark thank you very
much for taking my question uh whether
we stuck with either 10 days or 15 days
either one can you see any reason why
this should not apply to all payers and
not just to those who are paying out of
pocket
i really don't see any reason for that
beyond
whatever complexities might exist
in statute
or at the federal government level with
respect to medicaid and medicare payment
and my my sense representative canaric
and i cannot answer this definitively
for you is that that's probably already
taken care of i don't think that the
state is paying for
empty beds through its medicaid rate
if anybody here from the department
is here they could they could correct me
on that but i wouldn't think so
representative weber
i had essentially the same question as
representative knurk only coming from
the other direction
i was going to ask you how long medicaid
pays after somebody dies
i i just don't think it probably pays at
all after they die medicare
i think people have a misapprehension in
the general public that it pays for
nursing home care it does after a
qualifying three-day hospital stay
in full for 20 days in part for 80 days
so while it's a significant source of
revenue for nursing homes that are
engaged in rehabilitation
it doesn't apply at all when it comes to
assisted living facilities
any further questions for mr williams
seeing none thank you so much thank you
mr chairman
and the chair calls alex
kutrubis did i get the name right
it was your phonetic spelling that
helped
i appreciate that
and if you have written testimony could
you start it around uh i do not but i
can email it to you if that is
acceptable it is acceptable so thank you
mr chair and members of the committee uh
my name is alex kutrubis i'm here
representing the new hampshire
association of residential care homes
we are in support of the bill
just to give you a little quick history
we did have some concerns
with the bill as introduced however in
working with the sponsor in the senate
we were able to amend it into something
that we can support
the issue that we had with the bill was
clarifying that personal property and
articles need to be removed from the
unit before
rental fees would end
and that issue has been clarified if you
look at the bill as amended by the
senate in lines eight through ten we
feel that that adequately addresses the
issue
in most cases this is not a concern and
the family or the responsible party does
clear the unit uh very quickly you heard
senator gannon had the unit empty uh two
days after the passing of his mom
so it's it's generally not an issue but
occasionally there is an uncooperative
situation and um we're happy that this
language
was included in the senate version
uh so again we do support the bill
and the senate amendment takes care of
our concerns i wasn't
uh prepared to speak to brendan's
brandon williams's amendment however we
certainly would support
moving it from 10 to 15 days
and i do agree with him i've read this
bill many many times and
the the sentence
the month which the resident died shall
be considered for the purposes of rent
and fees the last month of residency
that sentence has always confused me in
this bill too uh so i i definitely think
if you remove it it would it would
eliminate any ambiguity or confusion um
because i think it's it's inconsistent
potentially with the remainder of the
bill
uh i haven't again we did support it in
full disclosure we did support it with
the 10 days in the senate however 15
days if connecticut's doing that we
certainly would not oppose that and i
think mr williams made some excellent
points of of why we should uh
potentially consider moving it to 15
days so so with that uh mr chairman i'll
um would you take any questions of
course any questions
okay thank you so much you're welcome
thank you
i am not
in a position to
put this amendment in given my horrific
schedule uh both of my day jobs are on
maximum the next two weeks if there is
anybody in this committee who is
interested enough in doing that
representative weber
mr chairman i would be delighted to get
an amendment that removes the
troublesome sentence on lines five and
six i'm not willing to change the the
number of days so if somebody is
concerned about the number of days then
they need to do it
but otherwise i'd be glad to get one
that just removes that sentence is there
anybody here who is likely to move to
present an amendment to move the number
of days
i don't see any
representative canarque no but i would
want to bring up whether representative
weber would be willing to take as a
friendly addition the just changing it
to all payers
if but we have to check out the hhs i
would not okay because i'm pretty sure
that it's not needed and it's going to
cause enormous confusion
got it
so it looks like the amendment that is
being prepared will take out that bad
sentence but will not change the number
of days from the senate
so with that i close the hearing on
senate bill 281 and we will bump this
down the road two weeks to the 5 and 14
the 19th
and the amendment will come in at that
point
opening the hearing on senate bill
fn
a relative to the definition of
alzheimer's disease and related orders
disorders
i was privileged to sit in on a one-hour
zoom session on march 29th
and also a person-to-person
meeting
with the speaker and majority leader and
numbers of people who work to care for
folks with alzheimer's the next day
so um
i've done my homework and who is going
to present this bill
who is anne oh you um okay
representative kanark
for the record uh jerry knerk
uh
carol three and i'm i'm introducing this
on behalf of senator kavan
kevin avard um i i also was in on the
phone call uh conference that we talked
about and since i prepared this for that
i just volunteered to him that i would
do this so that he would not need to be
coming over and it turns out he has a
conflict
so what sb 414 and i've passed along
testimony everybody should have it by
now it broadens the definition of
alzheimer's disease and related
disorders or adrd
in rsa 161 f66 to include individuals
who demonstrate adrd to an extent that
their symptoms interfere with activities
of daily living even if that formal
diagnosis has yet been made
the meeting this definition is necessary
to be eligible for respite services
under 166 f-67
the related disorders are things like
vascular disease lewy body dementia
frontotemporal and parkinson's
the point is that the respite program is
in place to support family caregivers
therefore that supports care in a less
costly home setting rather than um being
institutionalized but family caregivers
really suffer greatly because of the
time commitment when they're taking care
of their loved one at home that leads to
their own difficulties with mental
health and physical health we sort of
need to provide or support these
caregivers before they burn out not and
wait until after they've already burned
out and put their loved one into a
nursing home so the expansion this
definition is important to be able to
capture those
individuals that have become so
symptomatic they need a lot of care but
they've not yet received the formal
diagnosis or when individuals have
significant symptoms but they're afraid
to go to the provider because they fear
the diagnosis or because of things like
lack of access
there's often a delay of about two to
three years between the onset of
symptoms and the time of diagnosis
clinical diagnosis is easy when you have
a simple test that you can do that says
yes or no but it's really a lot harder
when you have a spectrum of disease
presentation and also when the early
symptoms can be really subtle like who
of us in here has not had a time we've
been a wee bit forgetful and kind of
wondered whether we're going down that
road too
never happens now you're right um now so
the definitive diagnosis of alzheimer's
and other related diseases is occur is
down at autopsy that's when you examine
the brain and you say yep that's for
sure what it was but the clinical
diagnosis can be fairly accurate if
carefully done but carefully done as a
key word it takes time
the clinical diagnosis you have to do a
careful history of the patient and the
family and have to take into account
that the patient's history often is
colored a bit by some of the coping
mechanisms that the family and the pa
prov
hi
okay
i got you covered welcome okay
come back when you can stay longer okay
[Laughter]
all right so um
for those who don't know that was
senator edward um anyway so take care of
the copy mechanism may hide it also you
need to do some cognitive mental status
screening tests sometimes you have to do
advanced imaging like an mri to rule out
tumors vascular disease
and some times neuropsychiatric testing
so as with any diagnosis some providers
will have a fairly low threshold for
making a diagnosis others may have a
high threshold and require advanced
testing before they're even going to
make the actual diagnosis but other
barriers that come in stigma stigma of
the diagnosis and the part of both the
patient and the provider the provider
may be hesitant to make the diagnosis
they may be concerned about the
diagnosis being distressing to the
patient or the family and the patient or
family may be in denial again that
moment of forgetfulness how many of us
go oh my god i hope it's not alzheimer's
so
they're all there are other systemic
things as well like the provider not
having enough time to really go into
this in detail when they have other
medical problems that need attention in
that short time and it can often be very
difficult for the family to discuss
mom's you know problems right in front
of her
so there's also last as always for those
of us particularly rural areas lack of
problems or lack of access due to lack
of specialist access and there's always
the usual cost barriers to obtaining
care so what this does
it improves the respite program by
increasing the eligibility to capture
the the caregivers before they burn out
and end up having to put somebody
into a nursing home that's really what
it's all about
any questions for the representative
mr president
representative delemus
thank you mr chairman i'll try to be
very brief
um i went through this i cared for my
mother at home
and it was a very long process seven
years make sure it goes to a question
so who makes the determination when
there's no clinical diagnosis i mean
could i have said oh my mom's got
dementia so therefore i i qualify for
whatever program
i actually had that exact same question
and i posed that when i was asked to be
a sponsor i think um
the
alzheimer's association may be able to
tell us a bit more about it or somebody
from the department who does the rest
but as i understand the caregiver's
self-report if the medical provider has
said that the person has uh qualifies as
having had that diagnosis but they do
not have a form for the medical provider
to fill out that is my understanding we
can get clarification from them
representative weber
and isn't the point of the change in the
disease that we are linking the
the entitlement to care not to an actual
diagnosis
but
to
a condition in which the symptoms
interfere with the activities of daily
living so you don't have to have a
diagnosis the qualifier is that there's
a substantial
impairment
of the activities of daily living so
that more people would qualify yes
exactly i mean that's because the point
is they may not carry that you know gold
card diagnosis as i have alzheimer's but
they are so disabled that that's they
they need it because of the activities
daily living that's really what this
build does it expands the definition
representative conner did i share with
you earlier when we discussed this
that my father had parkinsonian dementia
yes
which
is not alzheimer's disease right but
while the symptoms sure are running
parallel with it
that's the related disorders that's why
it's alzheimer's disease and related
disorders because there are a number of
other related disorders that are in that
like as i said it's a spectrum it's a
broad diagnosis um and in this case it's
a leisure if you have parkinson's you
develop it it's probably likely to be
the parkinson's dementia but in terms of
parsing that out it's the impact on your
life that matters it's not the exact
diagnosis that matters
representative delemus
sorry to beat this one um
so is it the caregiver i mean i noticed
that my mother was declining and
she was definitely you know was a
problem so would it have been myself
saying hey she's not doing well now can
you know she's got
i think from what i've read she's got
dementia how does this who gets to say
that you've got a decline if it doesn't
need a diagnosis as best i understand if
you would if you were this again it's
only having to do with this respite
program it has nothing to do with
anything else that if you're going to
apply for it you were to self-attest
they may have some questions about what
the impact does on activities daily
living if all they require is some very
minimal supervision of finance they
probably say that doesn't really count
but if you're 24 7 caring for them
that's going to count clearly do you
wish to follow up
welcome
thank you so would it would have been
myself or the the
i.e the caregiver who would
be the one to determine
well they would be the one to apply as
far again i will defer to the
the alzheimer's association behind me
may know the exact answer but likewise
if there's anybody here from the
department that does that program
they'll be able to tell you once it's
applied for how do they do the
verification i do not know that part
we i suggest that we call upon them
thank you so much for making your
presentation because the people coming
up next will probably better answer the
questions that have not yet been asked
call
mackenzie nicholson from the alzheimer's
association good to see you again
mackenzie and you've got things to hand
out do you
if you would take your mask off so we
may hear you please
they've been handed out
how are we doing you're doing great
thank you welcome thank you chairman
pearson and members of the committee my
name is mackenzie nicholson i'm the
public policy manager for the
alzheimer's association mass new
hampshire chapter and i'm before you
today asking for your support for senate
bill 414 and act relative to respite
care services for persons caring with
individuals with alzheimer's and related
disorders and making an appropriation
therefore
and before i begin my testimony i just
wanted to mention that wendy altman from
the department is here this afternoon
and can speak better than i will be able
to about
the process uh that someone will go
through to receive a respite grant
for your question um so
in new hampshire there are an estimated
26 000 individuals living with
alzheimer's or dementia and another 58
000 or so granite staters
caring providing care to those folks
caregiving of those living with
alzheimer's and dementia can be
incredible
you're muting me sir
apologies apologies
um so caregiving of those living with
alzheimer's and dementia uh
they have incredibly difficult jobs and
they often insist assist their loved
ones with one or more activities of
daily living um including bathing
dressing eating things like that and as
well as multiple instrumental activities
of daily living such as paying bills
shopping transportation that kind of
thing
83 percent of the help provided to older
adults in the united states
came from family members in the past
year friends or other unpaid caregivers
and in new hampshire more than 82
million hours of unpaid care to loved
ones experiencing alzheimer's or
dementia
alone happened in 2020 at an estimated
economic value of 1.4 billion dollars
in order to provide the care for this
loved one many caregivers report needing
to cut back hours take a leave of
absence or leave the workforce entirely
they also experience depleted income and
finances due to
paying for the health care services that
their loved one needs
the lifetime cost of caring for someone
with dementia was estimated at over 370
thousand dollars in 2020
70 of that lifetime cost is borne by
family caregivers in the forms of this
unpaid caregiving and out-of-pocket
expenses for items ranging from
medications to food for the person with
dementia
in addition to the economic burden place
on these caregivers
as the person with dementia symptoms
worsen caregivers often experience their
own increased emotional stress
depression and newer exacerbated health
problems
74 of caregivers or p of people with
alzheimer's or dementia reported that
they were somewhat concerned to very
concerned about maintaining their own
health since becoming a caregiver
evidence also suggests that providing
dementia care
can increase their susceptibility to a
multiple a multitude of
diseases and health complications
yes thank you
don't look at your text and just
summarize your points please sure so i
think that representative knurk summed
up very well why medical providers may
be hesitant to make a diagnosis
so i won't i won't pull that out for you
but we know that starting respite as
soon as possible is beneficial because
it helps reduce that burden off of those
caregivers the sooner the better
obviously um and so the reason that
we're changing the definition of
alzheimer's to include folks who are
symptomatic
to expand this population and get folks
who are earlier on in the disease
process is why we're doing this last
thing i'll say which is separate from
sort of the facts and figures about this
is just a little personal story is that
this is personal for me
my mom experiences some sort of
alzheimer's or dementia we don't know
what it is
my father who was her primary caregiver
uh takes care of her he for one for one
reason or another he doesn't push her to
explore a diagnosis he doesn't push her
doctors
very admirable but uh to that same front
he needs help he's in over her you know
his head with her care um and i believe
you know having access to a respite
grant could gratefully help him not only
him but the 26 000 plus or more
individuals who are living in the
granite state with alzheimer's dementia
so um with that i'm happy to take any
questions
representative merchant thank you mr
chair and thank you for taking my
question
if we
expand the program which i think makes
sense
um i saw a note in here that
it could possibly cause a problem with
current recipients because there's not
enough money in the budget to
accommodate that so are we placing
people in jeopardy who currently have
receiving respect care through the state
funds
that we don't have enough to take care
of everyone who may be
reclassified
thank you for your question
representative merchant i believe that
the department has
everything that they need to expand the
program right now including an increase
in the grant amount think thanks to
american rescue plan act funds
but when wendy altman is here from the
department she may be able to better
answer that question for you
representative cofolt
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question
um i'm curious about the inclusion of
the word irreversible
and
i've just been through this with my
father so i i'm aware that it's not
there's not necessarily an optimistic
situation but i guess there's a part of
me that wants to be optimistic about the
long term
dr dale bredesen and others i think have
explored
um
you know have have some successes there
so
my question is
does does the is the
inclusion of the word irreversible
is it is it necessary in your opinion
um would it potentially put some people
at risk of of not
qualifying um as advances are made and
perhaps there is some
new hope for people with alzheimer's
thank you for the question and i
appreciate your optimism um i don't have
the bill text in front of me so i can't
speak to that line but i will say that
alzheimer's and dementia are ultimately
fatal diseases as of right now and i
look forward to those advances in
science where one day we might not get
to a place where things are reversible
but as it stands right now alzheimer's
and dementia are irreversible and fatal
diseases
um let me ask you a question that
follows up on his question
if for some reason
my dad came out of his parkinsonian
dementia
he wouldn't need the extra care
that he did need when he had it
so it becomes a moot point
that was a question i would believe it
yeah thank you any other questions
representative weber
would you believe that as as i read the
bill the word irreversible only applies
when there isn't actually
an alzheimer's diagnosis it's the other
conditions that it applies to
so
it might um
eliminate for example a traumatic brain
injury
for which recovery was expected
but
it doesn't apply if if there's actually
an alzheimer's diagnosis i would believe
it
any other questions
thank you so much good to see you again
and
wendy altman
and i need to know what is the sops
campus are you in college
no sir i am not
okay then the follow-up is what is sops
it's the state office park south campus
for dhhs
yeah some of you didn't some of you knew
that probably
thank you
thank you um
good afternoon uh mr chair uh my name is
wendy altman for the record i am the
bureau chief at the bureau of elderly
and adult services here at new hampshire
dhhs
and i'm here in support of the bill
and i just wanted to make a few points
and have made some notes about some of
the questions that have been asked and
if you would like me to address those i
will
yeah repeat your title please
bureau chief for the bureau chief for
the bureau of elderly and adult services
thank you
at new hampshire you're going in my
phone so i just want to get it right
thank you
and i have hearing aids actually so it's
almost ringing in my ear with the
microphone but that's okay i can hear
that's good
um
so we support we support the definition
um the expansion of the definition this
is twofold
experience and observe the need for
individuals to have access to supports
and access to information prior to a
diagnosis
and we also know that many people
hesitate to
see a physician or a doctor to receive
that diagnosis
we do have resources that have been
earmarked to support additional dollars
that would go to respite grants
as well as to address
expansion
of the definition
if if that results in additional people
being eligible for the program we
currently have older americans act arpa
funding that will go to support family
caregivers
and this will be allocated to our
respite grants including our adrd
respite services
does that conclude your testimony
that concludes my testimony and i'd like
to be able to answer any questions
representative weber
as a follow-up to representative
delemus's question earlier could you
just explain what happens when somebody
when a caregiver applies how the
department makes a determination of
whether a grant is given
sure
currently our family caregiver and adrd
respite grants are administered and
operationalized through our service link
aging and disability resource center
programs around the state
we have family caregiver specialists who
perform options counseling as well as
information and education
they provide that directly to the
caregivers who are supporting
individuals who present with
characteristics or have been diagnosed
and are looking to receive respite
grants
and oftentimes
we will
work with those family caregivers and
that individual and we will go to see
them in person
and provide an assessment um looking at
what characteristics are they um showing
what kinds of needs do they have most
often
it's presenting with the need for
assistance with activities of daily
living and safety
representative delemus
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking my question um
so
i
in just an anecdotal thing
i did not know that there was this kind
of a program at all for my mother who
was suffering so
if you don't go to see a doctor to get a
diagnosis but you have a loved one that
you're caring for how do you know
where to go for this help
uh oftentimes
when we are monitoring and looking at
where referrals are coming from they're
coming from
doctors offices
places where individuals may have been
seeking or accessing other supports and
services such as senior centers
adult day programs
the alzheimer's association
and other groups that
may be helping either the family get
caregiver or the individual who may be
presenting with some of those
characteristics
representative mcmahon
thank you mr chairman and good morning
madam although
um
specific to rates of pay as this is
something we've worked on in the past
together matter of fact
uh is within this build is there a
opportunity for an increased rate of pay
for ds direct service providers to
be present and take these jobs as as
to take care of folks in their homes
so
the way the program is operationalized
is through an actual respite grant we
contract with a
fiscal management entity who would help
with paying for that support or service
for example
an individual may need respite for a
week to be able to go away we would pay
for respite at a
facility or assisted living or pay
somebody to come to the home
to provide that care
sometimes it's respite so the caregiver
can go grocery shopping or run errands
and do those kinds of things and it can
be the neighbor
or
um a family member or they can solicit
and hire somebody and they would choose
and direct how that care would be paid
for with the amount of money that we're
able to give in the grant
one follow-up thank you mr chairman then
to be clear there's not there's not as
has been in the past an arbitrary cap
to what an hourly rate would be to
provide this service under that
construct
correct there's no uh there's no guard
rails in terms of
caps on rates of pay or what we will pay
for in terms of respite
it
is something that's discussed with the
family caregiver service link and the
exploration of which care providers they
want whether that's
enrolled licensed providers to provide
certain care or
asking somebody to come into the home
thank you ms allman thank you mr
chairman
any further questions representative
merchant
thank you mr taking my question
i'm looking back on the methodology on
page
three
and if you look down it talks about a
fiscal
2021 there's 327 thousand dollars
appropriate for this program
it was reduced to 300 and 2508 in fiscal
2223 biennium
again my my concern is that i think the
policy is a good policy but i hate to
look at the policy and saying we don't
have the ability to either support it or
jeopardize those who currently use the
program
because i think we need to protect the
ones that are currently in the program
and not have them subject to
a harsh reality because there's not
enough funds to support the expansion of
the program
would you believe
a question
thank you
um i'm sorry this is blocking my view so
i'll try to
so um the the budget that we have in
biennium
2223 was based off of utilization in
state fiscal year 20.
um what we are doing is monitoring the
need
and looking to formulate any
justification if for an increase in the
next biennium in terms of a request for
funds to support individuals through
this respite grant which we would do
through the normal budgeting process so
we're monitoring for the need and
we'll ensure providing justification for
that if there's more funding needed
representative weber
so let me just ask about the arpa funds
you were talking about this was funds
that was already budgeted the the 300
and
am i right in thinking that first of all
with 327 000 that's already budgeted
and are there arpa funds in addition to
that
that are available for payment
going forward
i mean for a short time anyway
yes ma'am yes um representatives they
the
budgeted amount which is the 327 is
something that's general funds it's in
our budget the arpa funds would are in
addition to that and the time frame for
those older americans arpa funds go
through
september 30th
2023 so it brings us um it it crosses
over overlaps into the next biennium
so a follow-up mister
so what i'm understanding you to say is
that expanding the program is not going
to be a problem right now it's not going
to result in any loss of services to
those already on the program but
subsequent to 2023 we would need a new
budget allocation based on our
experience going forward is that correct
yes we would be prepared to
request
additional funds
for this budget for the adrd funds if if
the need is demonstrated and
we have justification for that request
seeing no further questions thank you so
much
and with this i will close the
hearing on uh senate bill what 14
and like to open the exact session on
the same bill 414 and i would like to
call on the chair would like to call on
representative
canarch for a motion
yes i would move otp
and i would like to second that
any discussion
ready to go
would the clerk please call the roll on
senate bill 414 dash fn a the motion is
ought to pass
moved by representative kinerk and
seconded by the chair
representative leon yes representative
mcmahon
representative acton yes representative
gay
representative cushman yes
representative folsom yes representative
kelsey yes representative king yes
representative cofoult yes
representative delemus
representative weber
representative mckay
representative snow yes representative
knurk yes
yes representative shapiro yes
representative woods
yes representative merchant yes
representative pearson yes 21-0 passes i
suggest it goes on consent
and also ask
it's gonna suggest you buy lunch but
never mind okay
and it's the exact session on senate
bill 414 i have a few announcements here
at lunchtime number one we you probably
have seen next week's schedule uh has
been changed
because we got
late
from the senate
some early bills
that have to be done next week and they
don't look easy some of them
secondly therefore we will meet on the
12th we will meet on the 19th
the next two tuesdays after this and
thirdly uh
she snuck out
i almost got her um
were there side by side handouts
available on the table over there
okay well i'll talk with her over the
lunch hour and we'll see if we got some
any further announcements representative
just a question of the chair regarding
scheduling
for the early bills they have to be out
by the 14th so that means we will hear
complicated bills and have to exec them
the same day has there been any
consideration to putting in a second day
on the 13th or 14th so that
if there were work that needed to be
done on those bills it could get done
and we could vote on it
there has been consideration but
i haven't decided to do it yet
if we get permission to do this because
it's a short turnaround
would anybody
object to coming in for a while on the
11th which is monday
and tuesday
all right let me check on that thank you
good idea
all right so so that would mean that the
early bills would be heard on the monday
and then exact on the tuesday which
would require changing the schedule
again which is a pain in the neck but i
think it would be really wise what i
will probably do then is move the
schedule has been announced from the
12th over to the 11th that puts all the
uh early bills up front
and then we get some other stuff done
and then take the leftovers from today
and any leftovers from the 11th and dump
them into the 12th and we might not need
the 19th and mr speaker
mr chairman
i i i suggest that you talk to the clerk
immediately about that because they're
going to have to do an addendum to the
calendar because the calendar on
thursday will be too late for a monday
hearing
yes thank you thank you
but he could do an addendum so don't let
him weasel out of that no weasling we
are in a no weasel zone representative
leon thank you mr chairman and i thank
you all for um allowing me to
accommodate this guy and i'd like to say
how thankful i am that there's a speaker
in that office so that i can participate
thank you
but not me no i'm not the speaker okay
thank you uh we'll be back at one
o'clock
imagine if we had remote access we could
have done it from home
but you get dogs and cats
representative snow being awakened and i
mean all kinds of fun stuff happened
one o'clock
karen a bear
hey
okay everybody i don't want to whack the
gavel too hard because of the child here
who has fallen asleep so
how's that huh was that good
it is not only non-german it is not
french and it is not italian all right
uh open the hearing on senate bill
289 relative to
the uh glucagon administration if you
remember the biden administration and
then the trump this is a different
administration so the chair recognizes
senator sherman to come on up and
talk to us
and i must say i thought my wife had
neat handwriting for a doctor but this
is fantastic no it's not mine
that's jenny you know
she knows not to let me do any writing
thank you mr chair and for the record
senator tom sherman district 24 11 towns
over on the seacoast please come visit
this summer
we uh this
i'm introducing sb 289
and just as an aside
uh i always feel like i'm coming home
when i'm coming to hhs so it's great to
be back with you all
this is a really awesome bill
[Music]
and because it's so simple and
um
i don't think there's anything political
about it it is just ex i'll just
read the blurb it's really
straightforward it changes the statutory
reference from glucagon injections to
glucagon administration
under the school health services statute
it allows for this
for the section heading to match the
language used in the rest of the statute
and also reflects that glucagon can now
be administered intra-nasally rather
than just by injection would you say
this is like a housekeeping bill
oh
listen i want it to pass so um
as do we all right
yeah um i wouldn't want to needle you
with the details
so
that was pretty sharp huh
um
you're injecting comments quite well
here we go i will get back on course um
so this will this reflects current
medication delivery system available and
i don't know about you but i run away
from syringes and needles so uh it
creates more ease and options for school
nurses and students alike and i also
suspect that it will
decrease the um
the hesitancy of using glucagon when
it's needed you know we use it all
in the hospital or in the er all the
time but the fact that it had to be
given by
injection
to children
is sort of this kind of speed bump so
the idea of being able to do it
intranasally is awesome and i think the
kids agree
so i hope you'll um
support it thank you very much happy to
take any questions the one question um
for the sake of the committee is you are
aware that representative merchant
submitted an amendment that arguably was
non-germane the
powers-that-be said well mr chair you
make the decision
the way you want so i said heck yes and
so there's an amendment 1223 and are you
um
comfortable with that
you know there's troublemakers
everywhere um
yeah i'm fine with it i thought so yeah
it was for them yeah
i'll flog him later
okay thank you any questions for the
senator
i understand you're quite busy lately
yeah i have to go down to transportation
it's
it's interesting it's a
my only experience in that was driving
my car so i'm in an ambulance when i was
16. but wow
um
it'll be a new experience anybody with a
question for the senator seeing none
thank you senator thank you
do we have another card for this 289
uh
i can lose things standing still
did anybody else sign in
uh
it's right there
come on up and while you're talking
we'll find your card
no this is
mike
uh senator sherman just did a great job
of going over it and i would not bore
you except that i had prepared stuff so
i'm going to make you sit through about
three minutes um you look like britney
o'donnell i i am yeah thank you you're
welcome you found my card i did
sorry
yes my name is brittany o'donnell um
that's what she
so i will read my testimony for you and
then i just have a little
little blurb to show you
good afternoon members of the committee
my name is brittany o'donnell and i am
the new hampshire chapter leader for t1
air national a global nonprofit
organization working towards affordable
and accessible insulin for all today
though
i'm here as brittany a type 1 diabetic
of 32 years asking your first asking for
your support on sb 289
i was diagnosed with diabetes at 13
months old and at the time one of the
youngest to be diagnosed in the seacoast
there was no carb counting no precise
insulin dosing the diet i was on was not
created for children with diabetes it
was a weight watchers exchange system
that required my mom to puree my food so
i could get exactly what i needed
nothing more nothing less
my insulin actually came from pigs and
cows at the time
there was no scanning your blood sugar
or reading it from your phone or taking
it
and taking it manually could take well
over a minute and a half just to get the
results
when i was four years old the
kindergarten program i had been in asked
my mom to enroll me somewhere else for
the summer they didn't have a staff
comfortable with dealing with a diabetic
when i was 10 and my parents applied to
put me into a private school
they were told they didn't have a
full-time nurse and didn't feel
comfortable having that responsibility
i was able to attend both of these
because of my self-proclaimed helicopter
mom who took the time to educate them
and to get them to see past the disease
and look at the child in front of them
from the time i started daycare until
the year i finished my high school my
mom used to go into each school year
requesting a meeting with any teachers i
would encounter
she would go over my tells of my high
end low blood sugars my ability to take
care of myself and most importantly how
they could take care of me in case i
couldn't do it myself
for most people the fear of diabetes
doesn't really come from what to do when
i have a high or low blood sugar
as long as i'm alert and sitting in
front of you you can assume that i'm not
in grave danger and that i can walk you
through it
and even solve it myself most of the
time
the fear is the possibility that at some
point you may actually be responsible
for the decision making most of the time
there are instructions on what to do and
how to provide care in different
scenarios
and heck most of the time now my
machines do it for me and you
but there's still that chance that we
miscalculate or my machinery
malfunctions or our bodies just react
differently and we end up in that
what-if situation where a low blood
sugar renders us unconscious and we
require glucagon
my own simple interpretation of using
glucagon is this the medication itself
is a hormone taking the medication
triggers your liver to break down an
emergency storage of glycogen
into glucose the shot is given in the
muscle usually an arm leg or your butt
to trigger your liver's response in the
quickest way possible the shot comes
drawn up with fluid as well as a vial
with a solid glucagon powder
to use it you have to inject the fluid
into the vial and without removing that
syringe gently roll or shake the vial to
mix it
once mixed you draw back the glucagon
into the syringe making sure to get all
of it before you inject it at a 90
degree angle
the final step is to turn the person on
their side because there's a good chance
that they're going to throw up
the reaction is almost instantaneous but
it can take up to 15 minutes
so giving you all that information
how many of you would be comfortable
giving me that
how many of you are trained in doing
that
um
aside from the size of the needle the
side effects are difficult after getting
insulin after getting glucagon you tend
to feel groggy nauseous and generally
ill for a few hours
it's not caused by the quick change it's
not only caused by the quick change in
blood sugar but the lingering effects
that the shot has on your body generally
it feels like your body is crashing from
a literal sugar high
in 2019 the fda approved an inhaler
glucagon it's used like a nasal spray
and only requires three steps removing
it from the bottle
taking a putting it in the nostril and
pushing the plunger for one dose
no mixing no shaky hands as you
administer a shot to an unresponsive
child no worrying if you can remember
the training on the spot most
importantly it kicks in seven to eight
minutes after use in 2015 the european
association for the study of diabetes
presented the data from a study that
tested out both forms of glucagon in
high stress situations the study
measured how caretakers and
acquaintances handled each in a
simulated low blood glucose scenario the
results found that there was a minute
and a half difference between
administering the inhaler versus the
injection and 94 percent of caregivers
gave the full correct dose of the
inhaler versus only 13
when giving an injection
none of this is to say that the
injection is ineffective in fact the
injection has been around since the
1960s and i have witnessed it being
given to fellow diabetics and taught
many of my friends how to use it on me
in the event of an emergency
in our house we actually keep both types
handy my husband is an emt so he's
trained to use both and effectively in
an emergency though i have joked that if
he ever uses the injection he better be
able to run quicker than i can wake up
what i am saying is that as a type 1
diabetic i would much prefer the
alternative one that doesn't count on
someone who may be afraid of needles or
panic in the undoubtedly stressful
situation but rather takes the pressure
off by giving them a much simpler way to
save my life with the exception of my
husband and a college roommate most
others i've given the instruction to
have said that they would likely opt out
of trying to give me the injection at
all and just call 9-1-1
with an inhaler they just need to know
where to find my purse
when the law was written in 2015
inhalable glucagon did not exist and in
fairness only one type had for over 50
years
advancements in the medication have
finally changed and in time our language
did
though i know this not would not have
stopped my mom from calling her meetings
each year i do know that it would have
provided her some relief to know that
almost anyone would be capable of
providing assistance if it were needed
and what an honor it would be to take it
that way off of another parent's
shoulders i appreciate your time today
and your support
for reference
i did bring the sweet looking needle
so you would have to inject it into this
vial did you say sweet yes i did
unintended thank you thank you very much
i've learned you appreciate the good
jokes
would you say that again i'm learning
yeah
you wanted the room to hear that
so this is what the glucagon looks like
i'm very fortunate i've never had to use
it frequently you'll find it taped to
the back of a door in a nurse's office
just in case it's needed
schools are allowed to train people
other than school nurses if they don't
have a full-time school nurse
to administer this
and make it easier the inhaler now
um
looks like this kind of like a flonase
it's pretty foolproof
our language in the bill itself is
really advanced when you look at states
like massachusetts and
massachusetts i think doesn't even allow
this for
people other than school nurses so
we are already one step ahead of people
we just really need to change the title
to be able to include the rest of these
items and anything that they might come
forward with in the future will you take
any questions i'll take any questions
all right let's try to limit it uh to
medicine and health okay yes
representative
so you think this is a really good idea
i do when
down the line and it's probably a few
years out
one of the things that the creators of
these glucagons these medications are
looking to do is use micro dosing
in instead of treating low blood sugar
with fruit snacks or juice
and
constantly feeding carbohydrates and
sugar to diabetics they're looking to
find a way to give small doses of
glucagon in some way shape or form
because without that sugar it's a lot
easier on the body and it's a lot easier
to predict
there's still a ways out but by changing
the language of this bill what you're
doing is you're allowing that freedom
for the things that come down the line
so we're not having this conversation
over and over okay thank you yes
representative leon
thank you mr chairman um i actually used
to work in the diabetes device space oh
and so that's why i noticed that you're
a pumper um my question is um i guess do
you know if they're actually moving
towards glucagon in the pumps yet um and
i believe that we probably need those
steps first with that micro dosing
that's being used separate from a closed
system before we can even get to that
point where the device can save the
person
so i'm not sure
there is one company independent of
these two that's working on glucagon
right now that has a different that's
working on microdosing i have friends
who micro dose glucagon right now off
label very off label
with that type of glucagon because it
lasts so once you once you utilize a
glucagon shot even if you don't
administer the whole thing this shot is
junk after 24 hours
so either you're giving most of the time
you're trying to give this person the
whole dose but even if you learn how to
micro dose with it if you're sick some
of the doctors will teach you how to do
it
you have to toss this after 24 hours
they're working on one that will be good
for up to three years i believe
which would mean that this could sit in
the nurse's office for three years you
go in you get your shot it stays there
the pump they are working
they have
i can never remember the name of it
there is one pump um we call it the
bionic pancreas in the community and
they are supposedly about a year out
um so i think they're working on the
micro dosing and that's i think they're
working with that other company um it's
beta
beta i believe um
and they are
they're trying to work on the micro
dosing in the pump so i think that's why
you haven't seen it come out that way on
the glucagon end
yeah
thank you very much for your testimony
thank you all i will is there someone
you'd like me to give it to i only made
10 copies i didn't expect such a turnout
for my
for my speech but well we heard
well we heard you were coming i know
look at that i'll i will leave these
here but these are just copies of what i
read okay
thank you very much and i'm willing to
bet that our wonderful
friend from the fourth floor is going to
turn 10 into 21.
watch how she does it
representative guthrie what
do we have a pink card for you
is your mic on
i didn't expect to speak mr chairman but
i couldn't go let the time go by without
thanking the committee mr chairman and
members for taking
the amendment
uh and considering it uh at this level
instead of having to go be uh before the
house
without the amendment so i just want to
thank the chairman the members of the
board and uh representative merchant for
uh submitting the uh amendment and i
support the amendment of course as did
the senator
and
i'm not going to try to say anything
after the previous speaker i'm
overwhelmed
but it's pretty clear that
it's a very simple amendment and thank
you for taking it at uh at this level
thank you so much representative canark
uh yes uh this
i only just caught this i would have
asked uh senator sherman would you
believe unfortunately that there is an
error in the numbering in the bill if
you look at line
two it gives the new heading 200 colon
40-b
but line 1 says amend the section rsa 22
colon 40b that also should be 200.
would you believe that that i remember
you were a master of the would you
believe questions that's in your honor
that i ask it as a point of information
instead i believe you would have you
would have a question
yes i'm having i i served on this
committee for a number of years
but uh that kept you awake all the time
that's in the main bill that's not in
this oh i'm sorry yeah well
we haven't introduced the amendment yes
i didn't think we were doing the segue
so this was the main bill but i do
believe that's a that's probably just a
scrivener's error that could be
corrected in enrollment i presume but it
is not correct uh
question of the chair for representative
weber are you
aware if they are simply making these
changes along the way in process like
they used to
i have no knowledge okay
because um
but if if we know that it's a problem we
ought to fix it right it's a lot easier
than finding out that they can't do it
with an enrolled bill amendment
which means we really can't execute this
bill today it sounds like apparently so
well
okay
representative merchant can we someone
send over a quick
request to ols to make the change and
send it back to us we could
i assume we could um but i want you to
introduce your amendment first please
and thank you representative guthrie the
reason i'm sitting here is because they
couldn't find anybody else and because
you said hey you ought to get into
health and human services a great
committee i'll take all the credit and
the blame okay thank you mr chairman
thank you
this ends the hearing on senate bill 287
and
now open
the hearing
on amendment 2022-1223
[Music]
the chair was given the option of how to
rule and the chair ruled it as
germaine but we are being a bit
fastidious in the process just to make
sure
well i think i've already got this
anyway yeah is she gonna is she running
enough to do that
eric is doing it right now oh wow look
at that yeah she babysits she amends
proverbs chapter 31
is this the same amendment as you sent
out or not
in the hearing on an amendment and this
is 12 23 is it this is on amendments
should be
2022 2141 i did not realize when you
send something down to oh wait a minute
you said 21 40 12 41 12 41. thank you
sorry i don't have that in front of me
just got passed around around passed
around
because
i found out from all ols when you add
another rep's name to an amendment they
change the full amendment the number as
well but it's the same language yes so i
rule this germain as well correct
thank you guthrie and pearson are on it
might as well do that
he's my friend coming massage so would
you like to introduce your amendment
please
okay these go this way
all right we're we're handing out copies
and if people could put them in the
places of people who aren't there such
as representative webber um
representative cannon if you could make
sure that she gets one too
from what's floating around here
and we'll let it float for a minute um
all right is this mine
all right thank you this is another one
okay thank you
everybody does everyone have a copy of
the amendment
does everyone have a copy of
the amendment 1241.
we've also got other paper floating
around too
i think we're looking good
representative merchant if you would be
so kind as to introduce your amendment
1241. and thank you mr chairman for the
record my name is
gary merchant representing sullivan
county district 4 which is ward 2 in
claremont new hampshire
this is a tale of two ships that
passed each other in the middle of the
night
what happened was we passed house bill
143 came out of our committee 1902
went through the house went through the
senate
everything was fine
in house bill 2
what they did was they took the
prescription drug monitoring program
which was anchored in 318 b
and picked it up literally lock stock
and barrel and moved it to
rsa 129a which is under the department
health and human services
so when this ship got to the dock which
was 3 18 b there was no longer any 318b
under oplc because it had been moved
so when i talked to ols they said
in the old days we could fix this
but now it requires a legislative fix
and i was talking at the meeting with
president guthrie at the board meeting
it was brought to our attention that
this was an issue
so i'm bringing before our committee to
make
a simple
housekeeping
change
um use that word dangerously but that's
what this bill fundamentally does is
allow it to be attached to 129a in its
appropriate place which is where it
should have been if it's still in 318.
simple as that any questions
and i believe representative leon you
have sent over a quest for an amendment
well
information mr
chairman
the
clerk has said it's that
the change for the bill itself can be
done with an enrolled bill amendment if
we don't have any other changes to the
bill well we do we have this amendment
i i have the language the question is
should we use your amendment and just
change that language in section one
so that there's one amendment to the
bill
that would be fine i'd be more than glad
to send it back to ols
and ask them to make the change that
represent picked up on there you go i
can email that to them and ccu so that
that can start in the process thank you
hopefully get it done maybe this
afternoon okay
okay
and uh
and while i'm have the mic before me i
want to also say thank you to
representative guthrie for pointing it
out to us at the meeting um he was there
as well he's on the board of the
advisory council and i wanted to say
thank you to him for his support as well
thank you so much uh this uh ends for uh
what is the correct board is it
recessing this hearing on 289
if you're not going to have any more
hearings you can just
uh close the hearing okay but we're
going to come back on to no no that's an
executive session thank you so this ends
the committee thing and uh
would you believe
the next bill is scheduled to be heard
at 1 45
walk around the building
yeah
well all right this
is
it won't take long representative canark
that's what i'm counting on
i did and representative merchant is
walking over there
on it
let's see that's why i waited to hit
send to see if that would be a minimal
stretch the
music from jeopardy to 11 minutes and 30
seconds
unfortunately we can't move ahead
because the next one's been calendared
for 145.
uh the one on that's the next one you
can all read through that hey wait i
have a great idea
we could go back
no could no wait a minute hang on
uh the announcement about whether we can
meet next monday i walked over to the
clerk's office that had already been a
supplement to the house calendar he's
not prepared to do another one so the
answer very quickly is no we will not
meet next monday we will meet on tuesday
tuesday morning will be taken up with
early bills from the senate some of
which are rather involved and
maybe controversial
so whatever we have time left for we'll
go through the rest of the calendar
and we'll take it from there if we have
to do it on to another monday we'll have
time yes is there any possibility that
we could ask for time on the wednesday
or the thursday which would not run us
into the calendar problems
i think different people have asked me
about schedule and i think there may be
a bit of a problem okay but um there it
is
so if you uh
the
christina daya has given me wonderful
things that i wasn't going to give to
you until the end because otherwise you
wouldn't be paying attention to me you'd
just be reading all these wonderful
things but let me tell you what these
wonderful things are and we can actually
talk about them
so i think i found
the uh 11 minutes gap in the tape has
been solved
uh each person should get one if there's
a seat empty like a representative gay
um
plop one there
this is all the same photo
wait a minute
thirteen you need to have
oh i see what i did you need to have 503
hb 503 okay
i need a 503
then there's another one coming around
well i'm going to hold on to that one
okay
these are bills that have come over
from the senate when the senate amended
a house bill
they came back to us in an amended form
you should have two single
sheets okay
does anybody over there have the extra
381s
yeah right here
when a bill comes back like this where
the senate amended a house bill
um
we have three choices
one is we can exceed to what the senate
amended and say that's fine with us
or we can say no way
we're not going to
and that kills the bill
or we can say well we disagree but could
we have a committee of conference
and then some people are appointed to
the committee of conference and it gets
hashed out
so i'd like you please to look at
381 just
this is a side by side on the left you
see the house version
in the center you see the senate version
you will see that they're the same
but if you turn over
you will see in the middle
down quite a ways
the senate added one section
a person under the care and custody of a
new hampshire county jail or department
of corrections facilities shall be
excluded from the provisions of this
section
that's the only addition they made and
the chair would like to know what your
sense is do you like the senate change
do you dislike senator representative
kenner actually there is one other one
that isn't highlighted the very last one
the effective date has changed but
that's trivial yes that is true
representative netarafam
yeah
cost us a lot of money so
why would they prevent someone
in prison from
accessing some kinds of tests
i don't know i i would
representative
i think what this has to do is
people in the
department of corrections they're
responsible for their medical care they
can't just go out to a you know the
corner somewhere and get medical care
and so i think the point is they need to
keep control you know how would they be
doing various testing and ordering
things up and getting uh blood drawn to
get sent there they don't usually like
extra needles over there i don't think
so i think that's probably what it is
representative woods
waving oh i say representative weber
and remember this is not preventing
people from getting lab testing it's
just
this is the one that's without a medical
practitioner's order and it's
people who are going to be private pay
uh
i i'll say for myself mr chairman not
anybody else that i i was against the
bill when it started and i'm still
against it but i don't think the change
is anything
that
makes a huge amount of difference
so i need a sense of the committee i
don't think it's a vote is it
it's a recommendation to the chair
that would be a matter for whatever
policy the current speaker has set when
it was
speaker norelli or speaker shirtless the
committee had to actually take a vote
under the president speaker um he said
mark do what you want with them so what
i want to do is get advice from my
distinguished colleagues representative
kanark
i would repeat precisely what
representative weber said i was against
this bill when it first came out i'm
still against this bill but this is not
the deal breaker this doesn't change my
thought on the bill at all so i'm
comfortable with this change
uh
if we have to have the bill passing
representative nuterapam i know i'm
chatty today i have made use of tests
that were not prescribed by my
prescriber um to get more clarification
so i'm
you know a responsible adult mostly and
um
so i'm in i'm in favor of this bill and
although i feel a little bad that if
somebody in prison was worried that they
had something and they were being
ignored by their
providers that they would be excluded
from this
but i will vote in favor of the change
this is really a sense of the meeting to
give me a guidance it's not a vote
representative leon
thank you mr chairman um i do think that
i have also done sort of the labs
without prescription but they actually
ended up contracting with somebody to do
it it required me to go to that facility
and i'm not sure how somebody who's
incarcerated would be able to go to a
private facility to do that so i think
that they're probably i know with some
of the other bills they had talked to us
about excluding people in the prison
system that are incarcerated because
otherwise they might take it as a reason
that they can push in order to get out
when they otherwise aren't allowed out
so while i do want to provide that that
flexibility to them i understand why
it's added and i don't see a problem
with it personally the clerk of the
house has just
texted me saying no vote is needed
it is recommendation so
just ask how many of you just show of
hands
would be in favor of exceeding to the
senate
version
and how many of you not
okay that's advice to me thank you
alrighty we'll do the other one later if
we have time
open the hearing on senate bill
fn
establishing a supplemental nutrition
assistance program this ought to be a
snap
i appreciate andy and all puns
good afternoon mr chair and uh good
afternoon members of the committee for
the record my name is becky whitley and
i am honored to serve new hampshire
senate district 15 including the
wonderful communities of concord
henniker hopkinton and warner
so i'm honored today to bring for senate
bill 404 establishing an outreach
program in the snap
existing stack program snap program in
new hampshire
so i'm sure folks on this committee are
well aware that food insecurity is still
an issue that we struggle with in new
hampshire and unfortunately it has only
worsened since the pandemic
we know that our low wage earners have
been particularly impacted by food
insecurity because of things like
stagnant income growth and of course our
high costs of living in the granite
state
but thankfully the federal government
provides support to address
food insecurity through the snap program
the supplemental nutrition assistance
program
and
folks are probably well aware of what
that program does
but it provides essential nutritional
aid to individuals and families
throughout new hampshire
these benefits it's important to know
are federally funded and dispersed to
eligible new hampshire residents who may
be experiencing food insecurity
so despite what we know is an ongoing
need for
nutritional assistance
there was a report issued by the new
hampshire fiscal policy institute on
july
15 2021
and that report showed
that there are more individuals
in new hampshire
there are more eligible individuals in
new hampshire than are enrolled
in snap meaning we have people a lot of
people in new hampshire that are
eligible and are not enrolled in snap
and i say that because i that there are
some trickle effects uh from that
so there are estimates that up to 17 000
children in particular are eligible for
snap and not getting it that means we
have children who are food insecure
who are not getting this aid
now to me that's a problem that's really
screaming for a solution
so not only are 17 000 children not
getting the aid that they're eligible
for
thousands and thousands of adults aren't
either
so this same analysis from the fiscal
policy institute which i'm happy to send
to the committee detailed that if these
17 000 children
had been enrolled in snap in 2019
and each child was in a separate
household that received the average
benefit amount during that year
then additional
37.9 million dollars and federally
funded aid would have flowed to new
hampshire to support those families and
to support our economy
so this estimated underenrollment may
not only may have resulted in folks not
getting this important nutritional aid
but of course that this was less money
an economic stimulus that was flowing
into our state during the pandemic and
to our local economies to our local
grocery stores
in this analysis the fiscal policy
institute detailed that levels of
underenrollment
in nutritional aid
of course continued through the pandemic
of you know we do we know that those
numbers didn't get better during the
pandemic right
data collected by the u.s census bureau
showed that significant portions of new
hampshire population face declining or
lost incomes and challenges affording
expenses in food
even while enrollment during the
pandemic declined
again this is a problem crying out for a
policy solution
so thankfully the federal government
does give the state flexibility to
expand eligibility for snap and to
conduct program outreach
which helps ensure that information
about benefits information about
eligibility is available to residents
who may qualify for assistance the
federal government reimburses states for
half of the costs associated with these
outreach programs so long as those costs
are part of an outreach plan that's
approved by the government so they allow
states to do that but it has to be a
plan part of a plan that's approved by
the government
and not only do they allow this allow
this the federal government actually
encourages these these uh plans because
of course they help improve program
participation and get more stable food
access to people
so unfortunately new hampshire has not
had an outreach plan for five years the
last approved outreach plan ended in
september
and so outreach eligible granite staters
i believe
can also help disproportionately
impacted folks
move for move ahead during this crisis
um you know we we know a lot of people
were disproportionately impacted by
everything that happened during the
pandemic and i think we have an
obligation to sort of find those policy
solutions to get them back on track
um so the bill before you is a very well
thought out proposal there are a lot of
very smart people advocates that worked
on this bill it also has bipartisan and
bicameral support um so i think that
speaks to how important this policy is
and
that it's really ready for prime time so
thank you for your consideration and i'm
happy to take any questions
representative folsom
thank you and thank you for taking my
question um
where could we find out what kind of
plans are
approved by the federal government like
do they have guidelines for establishing
the plans so that they'd fit there
thank you thank you for that question i
am not the best one to answer that there
are some nutrition experts dhhs might
also be able to answer that question
because they did have an outreach plan
in the past okay thank you thank you
representative leon
um thank you mr chairman
and thank you for taking the question
senator um this may be similar to the
other question do you know if they're
going through individuals financial
records in order to identify them for
that outreach or if this is more of a
messaging and advertising approach to
these outreach plans uh that would be a
good question for the food bank if they
were here okay
then i will defer to them okay thank you
thank you for that question i will say
that
the new hampshire food bank has
participated in outreach significant
outreach in the past present um and so
they are the really the best folks to
talk about the details of the plan and
how that might work
representative woods
uh thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking that chris i'm
here sorry
hello representative they hide me for
good reason
you mentioned a hiatus
about these programs was there a problem
that needed to be addressed
in the absence of these programs
why why were they discontinued
i don't really know the answer to that i
know folks from dhhs are here um you
know of course their dhhs has a whole
host of responsibilities and i you know
i don't really know why the outreach
plan was discontinued
like einstein said you're doing the same
thing over and over and expecting a
different result
is there something we needed to change
i think
thanks
i have a question here in the second
page under methodology
perhaps a little
unpacking on your part if you would um
the paragraph that begins at the very
bottom the department notes that in its
normal course of business that already
plans to apply for a snap outreach plan
um
[Music]
that makes me want to believe that some
of the stuff that's listed in the bill
is unnecessary but i'm not sure of that
thank you for that question and you know
i think i i'm glad to see that but
unfortunately we haven't had a plan for
five years you know we um
the stat program is established by state
statute and so i think if the
legislature thinks it's important to
have this component of it to reach who's
eligible then i think we the legislature
needs to speak on the
need and the importance of an outreach
plan even though the department's
planning on doing it i mean plans change
you know look
different responsibilities you know we
heard you know they it could be that you
know this takes not a priority i mean i
think i think that's fine if they're
doing it that wouldn't i don't think
that you know impedes what we're trying
to do here i just think it puts a
legislative imprimatur you know we have
three branches of government you know i
think it's important for the legislature
to speak on this and then the end of
that paragraph this bill indicates that
the resulting plan would not be
implemented unless its costs were fully
funded by private or federal sources in
other words no
charge against the state budget at least
right now thank you for that question
yes this has been um a really
collaborative bill
if there is a state there is a state
match for for this and there are already
uh private funds identified for that and
i think other folks can speak to that as
well how can it be fully funded by
private or federal sources if there's a
match by anybody the the private entity
would provide the state match
thank you representative cushman
thank you mr chairman um i believe you
answered my question
um
with your last statement but just to
really tie it up um for my own
understanding and maybe someone else's
um so really the difference between the
the plan
the
outreach plan
application that will be submitted
by the department and this one is that
the one that the department would be
submitting would use
their existing budget and this bill
requires that the funds come
from um the private and federal sources
was that a question
yeah
that's my that's my understanding
representative leon
thank you and pulling on the same thread
i see on page one line eight and nine it
says nothing in this paragraph shall be
construed to prevent the department's
use of available general fund
appropriations for the purposes of the
paragraph if there's insufficient
federal public public uh private funds
available so it seems that this is this
would this be enabling in order to reach
for those those private funds yes okay
thank you
any of the questions for the senator
seeing none thank you senator thank you
these were wonderful questions i
appreciate the time
keep those puns coming
chair recognizes elise bolster from the
new hampshire food bank
hi chairman and committee members
as you mentioned my name is elise
bolster i'm the registered dietitian and
nutrition programs manager here at the
new hampshire food bank
um you had some questions which i'm
happy to maybe address first or we can
save them for the end
i have something written here i think
it'd probably be more helpful if i read
it
well we don't like long red stuff it's
not long um
yeah i'm here today with my co-workers
um jennifer lennox she is our snap
outreach coordinator
she does some of the outreach that we're
currently doing at the new hampshire
food bank to ensure those who we serve
through our agency network do know about
snap and can access
snap applications through new hampshire
easy which is through the department of
health and human services or they could
call her especially if they don't have
access to
computers or electronic devices to apply
on their own they do need that resource
to go through that process and to have
someone on the other end of the line
that can actually help them through that
process
i think we can all relate to a
frustrating conversation with someone on
the other end that's not understanding
us or not helping us through our
processes
i wanted to
define food insecurity for you food
security which is
having enough consistent access to food
for an active active healthy life i can
imagine many of us have experienced
hunger at some point
i was hungry before i ate breakfast this
morning
food insecurity i'm fortunate not not to
have experience firsthand but food
security is as as i said consistent
access to enough food for an active
healthy life um and i think some of
those words within that definition can
resonate uh consistent enough
healthy
the mission at the new hampshire food
bank is to ensure that all new hampshire
residents are food secure anyone who is
eligible and enrolled in the federal
supplemental nutrition assistance
program also known as snap are able to
choose for themselves which foods to
purchase how often
and how much of those foods
this monetary supplementation again
supplementation it's not to purchase all
of their groceries with
it's usually not enough provides dignity
choice and options to new hampshire
residents on how they nourish themselves
and their families and helps us work
towards our mission of ensuring those
who are around in our communities our
food secure
without clear and trusted awareness and
knowledge of snap's existence how to
apply learning how one might be eligible
or where
to call or go to receive help our new
hampshire residents cannot access this
resource
and in turn might left be that left
might be left without the sufficient
food resources for optimal health
as much as the food bank would like to
provide all the resources at all times
to all of the individuals in the state
we cannot carry this weight
for those who are food insecure
and cannot care the entire way for those
that are food insecure
and this plan is the federal safety net
to ensure
that you know this program is help
helping to carry that weight
snap outreach provides the foundation
for this program
to be successfully util utilized
um and just we hope you consider the
fundamental need for this type statewide
plan uh so that we can
so that all can know about what
resources are available to obtain this
basic human need and
i can share a little bit about my
background at the food bank which is
that i wasn't here when the last
outreach plan was in place it was
contracted through the new hampshire
food bank
i started in 2017
as a coordinator and became manager at
the end of 2019 so a lot of this wasn't
in play when i was a manager and
something happened between 2017 and 2019
not to say that we have to be the
contracted agency in the state i think
as as far as the state goes they can
send out an rfp and anyone can apply to
be that contractor
the new hampshire food bank is more than
willing it's like i said part of our
mission and we would love to be able to
access those resources to ensure that
all of our agencies and the network that
we serve that are food insecure know
about this this resource that can allow
for them and themselves to purchase the
food where where they want when they
want and how they want to purchase them
questions
seeing none thank you so much thank you
very much
and the chair recognizes laura milliken
from the new hampshire hunger
solutions
now i'm going to ask you if you would to
remove your mask and turn the mic on so
we can hear you
there we go
so good afternoon representative pearson
and honorable members of the committee
my name is laura milliken i'm the
executive director of new hampshire
hunger solutions a non-profit that
advocates to end hunger in new hampshire
ongoing statewide snap outreach is
critical eligibility for the program is
set by states so new hampshire should
ensure that our residents who are
eligible for snap know it know how to
apply and can benefit from it
ongoing outreach improves the state's
ability to educate residents about
eligibility rules ensuring the program's
integrity
we know that new hampshire is now 39th
in the nation in snap participation
the majority or 60
of eligible older adults are not
currently enrolled
as many as a third of eligible eligible
children are not enrolled
in the week ending march 14 2022
over 55 000 new hampshire residents said
that they did not have enough to eat
that's more than the population of
concord
in the uh in that same week 25 percent
of new hampshire adults reported that it
was somewhat or very difficult to pay
for usual household expenses that's over
241 000 people
and these numbers are from the new
hampshire excuse me the u.s census pulse
survey
the rising inflation that we've all
experienced is also affecting food
prices which have increased over six
percent in the last 12 months
we are simply not reaching all those who
could benefit from snap and it's clear
that the need is great
statewide outreach is critical to
ensuring public resources flow equitably
and we know that outreach works studies
show that data-driven outreach and
application assistance increases
participation more than seven times in
adults over 65. an outreach plan
codified in legislation will have the
effect of saying that we in new
hampshire believe that addressing hunger
is a bedrock value
we applaud new hampshire dhhs for its
recent stated commitment to submitting a
snap outreach plan to the federal
government this year
we also support this legislation as it
will ensure that all future
administrations do the same new
hampshire has failed to submit a plan
since 2017 with clear negative effects
on hunger in the state and this
legislation will ensure that doesn't
happen again
so this legislation requires the state
to file an outreach plan but not to
implement or administer it unless they
receive private or federal money
sufficient to cover the costs
fifty percent of the funding is already
assured as the federal government
provides the fifty percent match now
while the state must submit the plan in
order to access that 50 percent match
because non-profits can't do that the
bill puts the burden of raising the rest
of the dollars on nonprofit partners
the bill is modeled after a nebraska law
where the new nebraska food bank for the
heartland raises the money for outreach
and administers the outreach program the
state's only obligation is to submit the
plan it's entirely revenue neutral
snap not only keeps our neighbors from
hunger but communities gain from the
multiplier effect of snap dollars being
spent in the local economy
for every snap dollar that comes into
the state it's estimated to stimulate a
dollar fifty or more in local economic
activity
so for example as senator whitley said
earlier the new hampshire fiscal policy
institute estimated that 17 000 children
may have been eligible for snap benefits
in 2019 but were not enrolled now if
they had been that would have brought
nearly 38 million dollars in economic
stimulus to new hampshire in a single
year
our system of food and nutrition
supports is like a power grid that moves
nutritious food to communities
throughout the state but that grid is
now patchy in some communities and
non-existent in others
this bell will help us plug more
communities into the grid ensuring more
children older adults and other eligible
granite staters benefit from the
nutrition
support that they deserve
thank you so much take any questions
any questions
representative leon
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question um i hope you can
answer what i have to ask here do you
know if the outreach would be
specifically targeting households that
have been identified as having the
earnings level where they would qualify
or if this is a broader outreach that's
not targeted to specific households
so thank you for the question um
i uh
i think that we would um want to broadly
target the outreach i um i
don't know that we even have the ability
to target as you as you indicate i think
we could use census tract data to show
what areas people might live in who are
snap eligible
but the idea is not to in any way
stigmatize anyone the idea is to make
sure that the people who need snap can
access it
follow up thank you mr chairman so you
don't know of any plans taking medicaid
benefits or anything else like that to
personally target any of these
families i see what you're saying so
you're talking about medicaid direct
certification so i'm aware of
medicaid direct certification for free
and reduced meals not for snap okay well
the privacy issues of that um were a
concern to me especially families that
don't want to be identified that way so
i'm trying to learn more that's why i'm
asking these questions i see i mean that
is that's an interesting way of looking
at it i sort of see it a little bit
differently that that's families who
have already submitted information for
medicaid
would be told that they were are also
eligible for other programs which uh you
know gives them the option to enroll or
not
so you would you would be in favor of
using that information to do to reach
out specifically to those families uh so
this this the snap outreach bill doesn't
have anything to do with medicaid direct
certification thank you
any other questions for the speaker
seeing none thank you so much thank you
and now
the chair recognizes
karen eber
bienvenue
madame
don't tell me it's hebert messi
good afternoon my name is karen a bear
or if you're not french or from canada
it is hebert
you
i am the director for the division of
economic and housing stability for the
department of health and human services
it's a long
title i have to take a breath in between
so i do want to uh
note that i
the department respects the policy
support
of senator whitley
as well as the support that we have been
getting
from a number of food advocates
across the state
so i do recognize that and the
department does agree that an outreach
plan
is extremely important to families in
new hampshire
especially with our increasing and
recent rising food costs
we were approached by a number of the
food advocates as well as new hampshire
legal assistants really supporting and
encouraging the department to conduct
further outreach for the snap program
and while the
caseloads in
the department for snap were encouraged
by a slight increase that we have seen
in the last month
what we didn't really see was an
increase in the need during covid so
during the last two years it was it were
the
caseloads remained relatively steady
so that's certainly something we made a
note of
so we've been currently analyzing some
of our own data
including survey very recent survey data
as well as other data that includes work
done by the children new hampshire
children's health foundation and find it
very informative so we've started the we
started a while ago to initiate
a request for procurement a request for
proposals rather through the
department's procurement process
for a snap outreach plan
while we're in the middle of that
procurement so i'm a little restricted
on what we can
disclose about that at this time
we do basically agree
that
an outreach plan is helpful and
essential for our families
a couple of technicalities i just want
to point out that are in the bill
one of them being
on line 13 of page one
it refers to
as uh
that upon approval by the federal
government
of an outreach plan
that the plan shall be implemented
within three months
and i just want to point out
the procurement process that includes
developing those contracts it's entirely
possible it could take more than three
months and i don't want to
get us in trouble if you will
so i'm wondering if it would be
acceptable to make an amendment to that
time frame so that we're not restricting
ourselves based on a process that we
don't always have control over that is
also subject to governor and council
approval for all of those contracts
a second technicality that i want to
point out is
on line 24
which that particular fiscal year 2023
actually refers to the state
fiscal year and i wanted to ensure there
wasn't confusion over
that versus federal fiscal year
the
deadline for the usda's
for our submittal to the usda for an
outreach plan is august 15th of every
year so the deadline for august 15th of
runs in state fiscal year 23.
the last thing i want to just note is
that while
we have been initiating the current
outreach plan
using existing resources in the
department
if the
bill were to pass i do note that it
refers to online 24 to
this as being annually or as required by
the usda thereafter uh it is entirely
possible we would seek resources through
the budget process
for a continuation of an annual
support for an annual
plan
and we would seek that in the next
biennium budget
we also don't
know at this time
we will be putting together relative
projections for the 24-25
budget based on how successful the
outreach plan could be so we can make
projections on perhaps the increase in
applications the increase in eligibility
determinations that our eligibility
staff would have to process
and if we are very very successful we
will need further resources for that
we're hoping
for success with this
representative weber
thank you and if i may mr chairman i
have a couple of different questions uh
the first comes from your testimony
about uh line 13 you said that three
months might be too limiting do you have
a time period that you're comfortable
with
i would recommend six
just in case i don't know that we would
need that but i'd rather be safe than
sorry
thank you
and second question on
online 24 you want the insertion of the
word state fiscal year or do you think
that now that you've explained it to us
we're we're okay
i think it would be helpful for that
clarification to and i uh senator
whitley did support that as well okay to
include the word state
okay and then
just you you made some sweeping
statements at the end about
uh
needing more
money but
just so that i am clear we're talking
about two different things one is the
program itself which might need more
money
but what we're talking about in this
bill is simply the funds for the
outreach is that correct
so the funds for the outreach plan
itself so what i'm talking about are yes
couple of different things so resources
that the department needs in order to
pull a plan together and do a
procurement process for that plan
so that does take resources to be able
to
to to make that happen
so if this were to be an annual
initiative for the department we would
certainly look at seeking an additional
resource
for
implementing that on an annual basis
right now we are using an existing
resource that we have
until the end of april
but after that we will no longer have
that resource so we will look at
incorporating something into the next
budget for that resource
the funding for the plan
essentially
comes from
the federal government that pays for 50
of of eligible activities or allowable
activities and what we anticipate is
that the other match would be raised by
the programs that bid on
the um
on a contract for that
thank you
any other questions
representative knurk
well then a follow-up on what
representative berber was just asking
would you be
happier if we did not have that
reference into annually so that you're
not obligated to do it annually since it
may not be something you would wish to
do on that basis
in other words if we're going to get an
amendment we might as well fix all the
language pieces in there
i think the department will be neutral
on that
because i think that
while the concept of having an outreach
plan
i understand the necessity to it and
support the need for further outreach
for families
but at the same time i want to ensure
that we have the resources in place
to make that happen and make it
successful
so the outreach plan the program from
the federal government is voluntary it
is not a requirement
by the usda
to have to conduct outreach but the
state certainly sees the importance to
it which is why we initiated it a little
while ago
follow-up i i think i understand that
but you you
as you point out you wouldn't want to do
it unless it's successful but i'm
concerned about the language here says
as well as annually or as required but
if you felt that it were not successful
so you did not wish to do it annually
is there an escape clause here because
it would only be if it were required
i think the or as required okay probably
suits that just okay thank you
representative weber
so do we actually need this legislation
at all is this not something the
department can just go ahead and do
without enabling legislation
so
the while it is voluntary it's a
voluntary program from the federal
perspective
the department has been neutral on
whether or not
this we haven't
the department is neutral on whether or
not we move forward with legislation on
this particular bill could i have a
follow-up you may
i understand that you're neutral on the
bill
my question is
it appears from
statements made in the methodology and
statements that you just made that the
department can go ahead and do this
program whether we have a bill or not is
that correct that's correct and the
issue is
whether the program will be initiated
uh within the parameters of what the
legislature has outlined here or whether
the department will just continue with
it or not continue with it
at the department's own
initiative
yes
oh could i have one more
let me follow up to you or your
follow-up and then you can follow up
okay so this really means if the bill
doesn't go anywhere
it leaves the department with a lot more
flexibility on how to do
pretty much this stuff whereas if the
bill passes it starts restricting it
am i right i don't know that the bill
restricts what it is that we're doing
any i think that it just is presented as
a supportive
um
policy
from the state
to encourage the department to continue
having an outreach plan for snap
follow-up representative weber
i was reminded that there was a question
a while back saying why was the program
discontinued five years ago and
it's clear to me that if we have it in
statute then the program is not going to
be discontinued unless the statute is
repealed
was there a statute if you know was
there a statute five years ago and and
was that repealed or did the department
simply discontinue the program and if so
for what reason i believe the latter i'm
not aware of any statute previous to
this uh that was repealed
and whether the department would
discontinue the program without
legislation in place i
it's a little tough to predict the
department certainly has a number of
competing priorities and only so many
resources so we look at really what
that that's an ongoing strategic plan
who has a question representative
cushman
thank you mr chairman so just um to
clarify that last statement so that was
the reason that it was discontinued
before because it was not strategically
prudent
i would be happy to find out that
specific information because i was not
in this role at that time um so i'd be
happy to get back to you if that's okay
with you okay great
thank you so much thank you
is there sentiment in the committee for
someone to write an amendment changing
the two or three little things that we
noted
representative kanark
yes i'll do that for you
i just want to we could take a moment to
make sure that i have them both it was
the line 13 and the line 24 adding the
word state and changing it six months in
13. did anybody have anything else
please let me know
before i start preparing it
particularly representative weber who
usually figures everything out oh
representative cushman if i may you also
made a remark about the word annual and
striking the word annual so that they
weren't bound to do it annually if they
find that yes it's not may i respond you
may respond uh well except as
ms hebert pointed out that says annually
or as required so there is an escape
clause that gives an option
um line 24 as well as annually or as
required so since it's not a requirement
but it's an option it seems like they
have the flexibility that they would
need
so she said
that she had no objection to leaving the
word annually in there
as i as best i understand
it's always good when's people are happy
and it looks like the house committee
services
are happy
to provide a legislative history on this
kind of a thing we are asking uh
were there such and we want them to be
happy
so we will it looks like we will um wait
for a couple weeks before we exact this
so let's
uh postpone this to the uh meeting on
the 19th and representative kanark uh
you'll be coming in with some an
amendment for us yes
thank you
uh this concludes the hearing on senate
bill 404
and i now open the hearing
on senate bill 439 relative to the brain
and spinal cord injury advisory council
and community
sup based support
program and the chair recognizes
senator gaida the prime sponsor
thank you mr chairman members of the
committee
it is good to be back in my old stomping
grounds
at least for now
where's your old stomping grounds yes
okay
so
my name is bob guyda i represent
district 227 communities up in the
central western part of the state
and i am prime sponsor on senate bill
439 fn
uh this bill is a result of a long
progression of things it began with my
wife's tragedy
that brought me into contact with the
brain and spinal cord injury
advisory council
uh a very well intended
and very dedicated group of volunteers
we had a number of discussions at their
regular meetings and the need arose very
clearly to streamline
the council because it had too many
members they couldn't get a quorum
and those types of things that i think
you see as well sometimes from time to
time
and so this bill is a result of the
consensus of that
council
okay
as to what they would like the or the
council to look like going forward
uh it um addresses some things that were
if you will again well intended but
dysfunctional
takes those out and i'd be happy to
answer any of the questions any of those
to any of the things in the bill that
any of the members of your committee
have to
to ask again it doesn't establish a
committee it just takes and cleans up
the bylaws and and
of the existing committee
i'm pleased to know there's only one
house member appointed to this
it will be you
i know that
[Laughter]
but i didn't mean that as much as i have
to go looking for
other members uh representative excuse
me senator guida
there's a few things now i'm very keen
on when i see committees and commissions
and councils having spent several months
with the education commissioner trying
to rescue a law because it was extremely
unclear as to how we should go forward
so i get appointed to that as a citizen
and so now i'm very careful to look i
don't see in here
and help me i may have missed it
who is the convener who calls the first
meeting together well mr chairman if i
may this council already exists okay
so it does the current chair
uh jim pete's
uh an incredible man
with an incredible disability that he
has managed to overcome i mean
incredible is an understatement
uh is the current chair he calls them as
it was too obvious why it wasn't there i
missed that
and also therefore who uh will elect the
chair that's already going on the one
thing that seems to be missing is
mileage for legislators
that may already or as far as well again
this doesn't establish a committee the
led the mileage for legislation that may
already be already in there okay
yeah just in case yeah any other
questions for senator geider
oh yeah representative weber
i actually had one but then i think i've
read a little more carefully i was going
to ask if if the commissioner of health
and human services and and the people
following him could designate an
alternate and i noticed that that is
headed by the following persons or their
designees so they can which is always
one of the issues when we have large
committees and commissions there's only
so much time that the commissioner can
spend in committees and commissions and
get the rest of their jobs done so but
the designees
are already there so that's okay thank
you
representative snow
that was the same question okay i was
going to ask
representative connerk yes i'm
hiding over here i had a couple of
questions um
one was the i did notice the rem and my
sorry i had to step out for a moment i
might have missed this if you said it
on page two line four the chief of
speculation special education bureau is
removed
um i was curious why that person would
be removed since it seems like special
education would be an area of quite a
big interest in this
or is it just because they were never
attending
that was one the other reason is again
this is a council that comes forth with
recommendations those recommendations
will be delivered to department of
education health and human services and
so forth as as as would be you know as
the report would indicate okay follow-up
follow-up up another one was i did
notice there was also language in here
about removing issues about grants and
gifts and i was wondering why grants and
gifts were being removed i
forgot now which line that was
yeah it's on page 3 line 11 through 13.
so they were authorized to solicit
receive any grants or gifts and that's
removed and i was curious why remove
that those grants and gifts should go to
hhs because the advisory council doesn't
have fiduciary authority statutorily
okay and one last one one more okay the
last one i had was one that actually
kind of troubled me the most there was
also removal in the duties
about issues about prevention
um
that it seemed like we were taking away
any work
for prevention work
and i was curious why that well again
the focus of this council is for the
survivors
of brain injury and spinal cord injury
it does not look at prevention it looks
at programs for example in the last
budget we appropriated 200 000 to
develop a training center for mildly a
brain injured folks down in the central
part of the state where one currently
doesn't exist but this is all after the
fact of the brain injury uh that's the
purpose of the association certainly to
discuss
uh you know preventative measures but
the focus is is almost completely on how
do we now help these folks that have
been afflicted
if it followed sure
was the initial legislative intent
though i mean usually the duties are put
out put in in the legislative intent to
the initial bill
was the initial legislative intent for
it to be dealing with prevention and it
just evolved to the point that it wasn't
doing that so might as well get rid of
it or was that not the intent
i don't believe that was the intent okay
thank you again this was formed because
people were with brain injuries had
nowhere to go right no resources
available and so it's managed to work i
got to give full credit to steve wade
and jim pete steve is the head of the
brain injury association of new
hampshire
and he has done yeoman's work in
coordinating with dhhs and any other of
the agencies in getting this bill put
together so
kudos to him and that organization which
is which does incredible work for people
that are suffering some pretty terrible
afflictions
any further questions for the senator
representative cushman thank you mr
chairman thank you senator for taking my
question um i noticed that this repeals
the brain injury registry um can you
tell me a little bit about that um
how long it existed in statute and was
it ever um implemented did it ever get
up and running do you know
i think part of i don't know the answer
to those questions but from my
discussions with the council it was
basically dysfunctional anyone that has
a brain injury
is either known already so this is a
redone that would have been a redundant
thing the brain injury association keeps
very close track of people
um
i'm not sure of the state's resources in
that capacity so i'm not enabled i'm not
able to answer that
okay thank you sure
seeing none thank you so much thank you
mr chair members of the committee and
the chair called stephen wade of the
brain injury association of new
hampshire
and since you've uh i'm trying to enter
you into my phone i have would you
repeat the phone number you've got down
here because there's one number i don't
quite
uh microphone please
603.
five six
eight
there it is it's red now
six oh three five six eight yes
nine two two one two one thank you so
much yes
chairman pearson members of the uh of
the committee my name is steve wade i'm
the executive director of the brain
injury association of new hampshire and
i can try to answer some of those
questions as well um that were asked of
senator gaida guida
but i'm here on behalf of our member
families and survivors
certainly strongly supportive of this
legislation
and some of the changes to the council
so i think one of the major roles of the
council over the years has really been
to try and identify some of the gaps in
services and unmet needs of people
living with brain injury which has been
very much an underserved population
particularly children with brain injury
and especially children with
co-occurring
brain injury and neurobehavioral health
issues so
um so the council does a lot of work in
terms of holding hearings and listening
sessions and working with the support
groups
all as volunteers again trying to gather
information for an annual report that
goes to the legislature and to the
health and human services so
um
there were oh actually i also have a
letter from jim piatt jim um
senator guy to mention that jim is
currently the chairman of the uh of the
council and um
uh if it's if i if it's okay with you
i'd like to read that letter of support
it's brief yeah it's very brief actually
my name is jim piatt i am the chair of
the brain and spinal cord injury
advisory council the council has been in
existence since 1997 when it was
established by statute rsa 137k
i'm writing on behalf of the council to
ask for your support of sb 439 fn an act
relative to the brain and spinal cord
injury advisory council and community
based brain injury programs our
council's been working with senator
geider on this proposed legislation that
would streamline the council membership
and continue our work in a more
effective manner if you have any
questions please contact me and list his
phone number so actually i have copies
of the
letters of support i probably should
have given these to someone if i could
pass them over so
but in terms of answering some of the
questions would it be okay if i took a
stab at that i know there was a question
about the registry um i know when the
law was originally a past
establishing the council there was talk
about actually putting together a brain
injury registry modeled after some of
the other registries and i know at that
time the legislature was concerned about
issues of confidentiality and i think
the feeling was could we do this without
actually having a formal registry and
i'm pleased to say that we it has been
very successful um
health and human services developed a
program called the acronym is wisdom i'm
not exactly sure what it stands for but
one of the major purposes of registries
of course is to put together your your
your um incidents and prevalence data
for the state so the the health and
human services does have that data uh
and and produces it not on an annual
basis but on a somewhat regular basis
from hospital discharge data that the
state has the other purpose of the
registry was to link
newly injured folks up with state
services and community-based services
and health and human services did fund
through the bureau of developmental
services
essentially essentially navigator
positions neuro navigator positions to
work with folks again post looking at
the post acute long term chronic phase
of brain injury the hospital your
hospitalization is just the start of
really oftentimes a long journey so um
and that those um those resource
navigators work very closely with the
all the acute rehab facilities in new
hampshire and many of the hospitals to
work with newly injured families to help
them identify services at the community
level so essentially although we don't
have a formal registry in new hampshire
all the functions of a registry are
being accomplished
so
and that's probably fairly typical of
other states as well
particularly our neighboring states
so there was one other question besides
the registry that someone oh the
prevention question i think um so
there is a lot of brain injury
prevention work being done and it's
primarily being done by the injury
prevention center up at dartmouth
as well as i know health and human
services has some injury prevention work
as well and then the brain injury
association does a lot in terms of
injury prevention but the core focus of
the council really has been to try to
identify unmet needs of folks living
with brain injury those who've already
sustained an injury so
i hope that hope that helps answer a
question so i'm happy to answer any
other questions that anyone may have so
representative knurk
thank you and actually it was not until
after doctor
sorry doctor got it senator guida uh
left the chair that i realized there's
still kind of a bit of a follow-up on
that chief of the special education he
commented that because this particular
council comes up with recommendations
and especially it would be more of it
something that implements it but yet
when we come up with a recommendation we
don't want to come up with a
recommendation that can't be implemented
is it not helpful to have those who have
to implement be at the table to make
sure that what we draw up is still
effective again i don't know the
internal workings of it so if if you who
have been there still feel it's better
not to have that person i would
understand but i just have wondered why
it just struck me as funny because it
seems like a large role no certainly
again brain injury affects children
perhaps more so than adults and new
hampshire actually has a code within
the idea for acquired brain disorders it
was originally just traumatic brain
injury but i think new hampshire was
very took a very positive progressive
approach and really broadens that coding
so children with brain injury are being
identified um i think the reason that
that particular category was taken out
is because there is already
representation from the department of ed
on the on the council and oftentimes uh
folks from uh department of ed will be
called in a specialist if there are
specific questions but there is always
in fact jim piatt himself the chair
works for the department of education
you know through voc rehab so understood
so
any further questions
thank you so much thank you very much
this ends the
hearing on senate bill 439
i'd like to go ahead and
exec this one i don't see
that we should have too much trouble
doing that so uh
open the
exec session on senate bill 439
and the chair calls on representative
folsom
for a motion
to pass on senate bill
do we have a second from
over there representative canark
now discussion what
it's okay it's okay
you were discussing meaningfully yeah
any anybody want to share speak talk ask
representative cushman
thank you mr chairman um i'll i'll try
to make a brief i was speaking with a
member of the community who
is a brain injured person
who's dealt with
the baa of new hampshire and
has been privy to what's going on with
this registry for a while and
apparently the law was passed in 2000
and it never
came to be and there were i guess
they're basing
their surveillance now off of data from
wisdom but dhhs
has reported that it's not capturing all
of the
um brain injuries and spinal in spinal
cord injuries
so i i i do support passing this bill
today
and just wanted to state for the record
that
um
that something that was in statute to be
done was never done
and um there may have been a disservice
to some people
who did encounter brain injury and were
never counted into that system and i
hope that perhaps next year someone will
bring forward a bill
to address that issue
thank you
uh in my first term
i got a phone call and then a couple
months later a follow-up phone call from
an individual who was serving on this
group
and had all kinds of
problems
with it
and
he called me a couple of days ago and
said that what senator geider has
brought forth here
uh wonderfully addresses all the
concerns that he had as to why the group
wasn't functioning as well as it could
and so on and so forth so that's just a
little shout out to the bill anyone else
representative folsom
i'm on that council and i never remember
meeting with them and having a quorum
all to the good
is that
seeing nothing further when the
trainee clerk
is ready
she may call the roll
and it is on senate bill 439
and
it was
it's relative to the brain and spinal
cord injury advisory council and
community-based support program
moved ought to pass by representative
folsom seconded by representative canark
would the trainee clerk please call the
role
thank you mr chairman representative
leon yes
representative mcmahon
representative acton yes
representative gay
out of the room representative cushman
yes
representative folsom yes representative
kelsey yes representative king yes
representative cofolt yes
representative delimis
representative weber
representative mckay
representative snow
representative canark yes representative
salloway
representative cannon yes
representative nutter eppm yes
representative shapiro
representative woods yes
and representative merchant
yes
and representative pearson yes
she wasn't doing it simultaneously with
checking 18 18.
so 18 to
zero
i move that we can send what's that on
the consent
okay the chair would be negligent if he
didn't uh inform
the trainee clerk that they don't all go
this
unanimously
and representative folsom will be happy
to write the committee report
uh we still have a few minutes before
the next
bill will be heard and so i'm going to
pass some things out this is another
please advise the chair
i'm passing this one out i know you have
another one but this is an easy one as
well
this is house bill 1390 you will see on
the left the house
uh version with a typo and the senate
voted right along with the typo but made
some changes too and you will see them
in the middle and so
you will see when they come
coming
i'll tell you again
was that okay
hi
wow
thank you
yeah we'll be with you guys in about
four or five minutes
yeah
that's us representative canark we're
heard of hearing
you didn't hear me
that's the point oh never mind sorry
yeah we're good
can you clarify i'm just a little
confused here
in terms of what
what we're looking at in terms of how
this is laid out and that is
the changes are highlighted in the gray
yep
should be
okay
so for point of voting mr chairman of
order
is this basically something that we sent
over to the senate they modified it and
sent it back to us we're looking to
concur
yep
and they want my opinion on whether i
agree i disagree or disagree and call
for committee of conference and although
i don't have to i want to i want to get
your advice and guidance and thoughts
and so on before i make my decision
if you look in the right hand column you
will see the asterisk picks up and says
it's a drafting error
mr chair given given that there isn't a
house session between now and next week
and given that there's
a significant amount of change and
i for one am really tired
would you like to take this home and
think about it could we take it home and
look at it and bring it back and
think about it and also the big thick
one called 503. if you want to do that
that is wonderful there's no
immediate urgency
all right
uh
before we
before we leave this
i am even more baffled than usual
if one looks at you
if we look in the first grade it says
amend rsa 310a
as a title is about architects
i have some a little bit baffled on why
why the architects are doing this
um
and i'm wondering if
they have a drafting error this
remembers the one where i picked up two
different statutory reference errors or
one was where it should live and by the
way i was privy to some of the stuff
that was going on there they
insurance people had concerns about
where we placed it you may recall that
there was a concern where she'd reside
in statute whether it was dhhs or
insurance it got stuck into the 4-1-5
they didn't like that so they're going
to find a new home but now it says 310
which is architects which doesn't not
make a lot of sense that's one of the
reasons i'm highly baffled
uh representative leon is looking that
up maybe a few well i've looked up 310
but i'm trying to i'm going to go back
to the bill and see if there's something
wrong and what's written here it's in
310-a so 310 is architects and 310-a is
the office of professional licensure and
certification thank you because we like
to make things very clear wait a minute
take them home look at them
let me know what you think
uh will we have a discussion on it or
will it be yes and thank you for picking
it up or are we going to actually come
back to this and do it together do you
want us to individually just let you
know what we think sure
that was a bit of a vague answer sir
you can
if it looks like i'm getting a good
consensus coming in from some from
everybody then i won't
do it in a group but if yeah and thank
you so much it's it's the same thing as
that that f dash f versus colon f that i
found in that 1347 it's like duh thanks
for picking it up absolutely and i
looked it up because you brought it up
so thank you
okay i don't want to do this anymore i
want to do something else all right open
the hearing on senate bill 279
establishing a study committee
on harm reduction harm reduction and
overdose prevention
program senator waters welcome well
thank you so much mr chairman members of
the committee for the record i'm senator
david waters from district four and i'm
here to introduce senate bill
by brief way of background i come to you
also as a legislative member of the
governor's commission on alcohol
and other drugs and this bill is one
that was worked on
with the new hampshire's provider
association and he'll representative of
them testify uh later on um you know new
hampshire
has been much beleaguered by
overdose deaths but we've made a lot of
progress as well i mean you on this
committee know and have done are
responsible for a lot of progress that
we have made
i've seen it on the governor's
commission
the recovery community the recovery
centers around the state have done
really an extraordinary job we've seen
governor sununu's leadership with the
doorway program
so we put a lot of good pieces
uh together there are still a lot of
overdose deaths in the state as we know
and it does seem by people in this uh
area
that one thing perhaps we could do more
on was
harm reduction overdose prevention
programs that's that's is still
something of a missing piece of the
puzzle uh you know whether it's drug
courts to the doorways or other programs
we have found ways to help
uh folks who are you know looking for
treatment or in re or in recovery uh but
if we want to prevent deaths
maybe this is something that we should
look into
so um what it proposes as you'll see a
lot of findings and it certainly
recognizes the situation that we're in
with overdose deaths in the
state and
what harm reduction overdose prevention
programs are
discussed here
as well
that there are 165
of these overdose prevention programs
operating in 10
countries and looking for potential
alternatives as well to the legal
justice system being the kind of first
stop
for
this issue as well so what the bill
intends to do is to have us take a look
to have a study for a few months and be
able to make some recommendations for
legislation now in the senate i will say
that we look we've looked at this for
the last couple of years and we were in
the middle of uh passing a bill a couple
years ago covert came along some kind of
further you know after
a strong support unanimous vote in our
our health and her
human service committee then decision to
take another look at it and so on and in
a way that that couple of delays um has
been useful because programs have opened
up
and uh i can just mention that if you
look uh do a search for the new york
city program that's been open up and
operating long enough to have some
reporting on it and some statistics on
it you can search that you'll find some
extensive articles about it in the new
york times
also since we began talking about it
rhode island has passed a pilot program
and if you go to medpage today you can
find reports on what rhode island is
doing and again we'll be getting data
from that and massachusetts and
philadelphia and some other places
around the country are looking as well
plus all the um
uh foreign countries that have
undertaken this um and there is well you
know one of the kind of larger
peer-reviewed studies that looks at 22
programs that are
reviewed you'll find in the uh
journal of preventive medicine so you
know the internet's a wonderful thing
right so you can go out there and look
around and just see what the way the
land is and that's the kind of work that
i hope this committee can do over the
next
few months take a look what's out there
now we have some data about how they're
done and then see what might work for
new hampshire uh and so that's what the
you know the study committees put
together and can make some
recommendations to us and i i do hope
that next year we will be ready uh to
legislate in this area and see if new
hampshire is ready to have some uh
overdose prevention harm reduction
programs um enabled uh as an option for
municipalities
to to take on
thank you mr chairman i'd be glad to
take any questions
it would seem that from the time it's
likely to be signed into law until the
report is due on november 1st you might
meet two or three times at most
so it's not a forever committee it's
go in do your job
report and that's it thank you mr
chairman and i think that's just about
right as i said we're now getting a lot
of data and i think that this will let
people focus and concentrate on what we
can
think might work for new hampshire
any questions for the senator
representative um
shapiro
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question
um
it seems to me that this kind of issue
the people are very opinionated about
this kind of issue that um people tend
to have a fixed idea about whether
um providing a place for people to come
and inject themselves with drugs is a
good idea because it prevents overdoses
or it's encouraging drug use so
given the fact that i am going to get to
a question
given to the fact that this is
an issue that is
likely to be contentious
um
and um in my mind
might be a very good idea
what is the distinction between having a
study committee
where a few legislators
have experts come and testify before
them and then write up a report what is
the difference between that activity
and just proposing a bill where once
again
experts will
come out of the woodwork to testify in
front of a committee about a specific
bill
given the given the problem with
recruiting people to do
study committees
i'm trying to figure out what are the
what's what the real distinction is
between those two things
well thank you representative for your
question and um you really do get kind
of the heart of the matter i think we
face as legislators all the time there
are likely to be strong opinions once a
bill emerges
and um
you know we're really really pretty
cherry of establishing commissions
especially in the second year
and i will say just to kind of back up a
little bit that i did try to put
together a bill
originally on this uh three years ago or
two two years ago excuse me
and um it was based on our uh needle
exchange bill had all the same
provisions of how you'd set it up what
the wrap arounds would be in terms of
medical personnel and approvals and it
was enabling and so you'd have the law
enforcement neighbors the municipality
agree and and so on that was kind of the
model that was there but the issue came
up right away about well is this going
to cause more crime or is this going to
enable more people
to do drugs than otherwise would have
and would would it help people actually
get treatment or get healthy or you know
get into recovery so
good questions i think what is useful
about this is we've got some data now
and i think that this study committee
will be focusing very carefully on okay
given that these issues are likely to
come up how do we write a bill and i
think a smaller group actually can do
that do that more effectively uh and uh
you know once something's introduced of
course then
the fair is open right and what happens
happens but i i would hope that we'd be
able to provide some very good answers
and information through the through the
study committee
senator
along the way have you identified
for me
three representatives who are keenly
interested in this since i'm the one the
speaker's office often asks to go
recruiting
along the way as you've studied this and
talked it up and so on do you have some
people that i could call you and say who
would be good on this and you'll give me
the answer
yes wonderful
thank you
representative weber
thank you mr chairman and thank you so
much for being here and for taking my
question
i'm looking at line 27 and i was kind of
hearing mixed messages
uh it it says it is the intent of the
legislature that opps should be
evaluated in new hampshire
municipalities that authorize them are
are opps currently authorized at all in
new hampshire and are there any
operating here at all
well thank you for the question and i i
i agree looking at the line it does
create that confusion but the reason
it's in there is that let's say
that a bill is introduced and it passes
this is a signal to this group that
would work on this the study committee
that you'd better have
continuing studies
in the legislation for those communities
that may
adopt adopt this so i think it's partly
the verb tenses there
but no there are not at this point in
time in the state of new hampshire
representative merchant
thank you mr chairman thank you taking
my question senator
um
i served on the
pharmacy board for 10 years
and part of that time was overseeing the
prescription drug monitoring program
which also deals with the same basic
issue
on that advisory council is currently a
requirement for two house
representatives and one senator
um is there any thought about utilizing
that
council
instead of creating another commission
is going to the council and having them
help you guide through this process
because part of their
requirements
is to
look at rulemaking as well as future
legislation so my question is have any
thought about
instead of creating another commission
another committee is using what is
already in existence dealing with
something comparable to the same subject
matter
well thanks for the question i have two
answers to that i actually think that um
you know given the
function and purpose of that existing
group and thinking that this is going to
be done by november 1st 2022 that we
might actually be able to get more
attention through this vehicle and then
secondly i think what's different here
is that this
is going to involve connections to a lot
of groups that you may not deal with so
much
the recovery community
recovery centers
police departments
other law and
other law enforcement municipal
municipalities so i i think it's very
very focused but also
um
you know might be a little more of a
stretch for the group that you're
referring to
follow-up
thank you thank you for that senator
when i looked at the composition of the
advisory council many of the people
you're talking about are currently on
that council
so i'm trying to do is look at the
legislative calendar and saying can we
use a vehicle that is up and running
today and try to get this done sooner
than later i'm not i think the intent of
what you're trying to accomplish senator
is
great i think it's something we have to
do because fundamentally what i've seen
so far is that when we talked about
reducing illicit use of prescription
drugs we never talked about the
underlying problem which is addiction
and what we've done is moved the
addiction from a pharmacy to someplace
else we never dealt with the issue of
addiction with it and i think that would
be a good tie-in between what's
happening now is working with an
existing group made up of physicians
police departments the ag's office and
so forth
to probably try to spearhead your
initiative sooner than later
well i appreciate that interest there's
nothing and i will say representatives
nothing to prevent you from doing that
anyways
i think that what is different here from
the larger picture of addiction and
recovery is that this is focusing on
harm reduction uh and overdose
prevention programming which is a rather
specific initiative that's being
undertaken and that's that's what i
think this is about
representative shapiro
yes thank you mr chairman and just to
piggyback upon the previous question
um
this issue came up i think a year ago
and um
i'm serving on the commission on the new
hampshire
drug overdose fatality review commission
um and i thought that this was a perfect
thing for them to study so i brought it
to that commission to say is this
something that we could study and would
you believe that they just felt like
even though it was so close to their
mission
that they were just overwhelmed with
setting up a fatality review commission
and um
were not able to take on another um task
like this i don't know if that would
apply to the other commission
thanks for your comment
representative acton
thank you mr chair and uh thank you
senator
um
just a quick point of information i'm
i'm the uh
the sole
state representative on the um
opiate abatement advisory commission we
got the bill this morning i've largely
stayed out of the money fight but i am
very much interested in this type of
information so would you believe senator
that
if you do move forward in seating a
committee a study committee i would like
to volunteer for that or if there
happens to be an ad hoc
group over the summer to do studies that
can be available for that as well okay
there's one well uh thank goodness would
you believe i'm i'm delighted to hear
that
all right waters
yes representative
uh thank you mr chairman and thank you
senator for being here with this bill
i'm not sure if you also read a
relatively troubling investigatory story
from nhpr about some issues around some
of the recovery houses
i'm just hopeful that anything that's
going forward with these opps where
people will be in in vulnerable
situations that any potential for a
misuse of trust will also be addressed
so would that be true
thank you representative and um
you know i i
i appreciate that story is a tough story
i've worked very closely with a lot of
the recovery
centers in the in the state and i know
it's of great concern
and um i think any legislation that
comes forward is certainly going to have
to make sure that we do it right
representative weber
thank you mr chairman and because
the chairman had this question with
respect to another bill
the
i'm looking at the drafting and although
it's a senate committee i noticed that
the house members are put on first and a
member of the senate is put on after
traditionally
senate committees have been convened by
senators and they're usually named first
and
senate committees are generally staffed
by senate staffers
so
i just want some assurances because we
have had problems in the past with
uh house members being told that they're
going to staff senate
created committees and i just want to be
sure that this
is a senate committee with the senate
convener and senate staffing because our
staff
is very small relative to the number of
people they serve
well indeed it is a senate committee and
that would be my um
thank you representative that would be
my
assumption but if you'd like to make
that assumption uh
even clearer you could say that um you
could add that the first meeting was was
called by a member of the senate
yeah and that would that would make sure
yeah the back story to this is i had to
spend several months working with a
commissioner because it was a wonderful
bill signed into law
but who is bold enough to call the first
meeting it wasn't in the bill so i got
appointed not as a representative but as
a citizen and we all looked in different
directions in whistle dixie and we got
it going but so i'm keen on some things
and thank you and
you know i i think that they
owe us a boy or boilerplate for
for study committees but i think it
would be good to specify that the
senator calls the first or you could
just do it in representative and two
others will just show up
study club
point of order sir line 17 already says
the senate the senate member calls the
first meeting oh i missed it it's all
right it's already in the bill i know
i'm not supposed to speak because i've
got it
yeah line 17 already states this
i did too
and i'm usually keen it's that time of
day the eyes are glazing
i didn't see it last night either
okay anybody else with a question for
senator juarez
representative snow
mike
this is a good time for here it is
once again
mr microphone follows it up again
a few years ago i was placed on a study
committee like this
senator and three of us when narcan
first came out oh yeah and of course the
speculation then was this is just going
to increase drug abuse because all these
people that are abusing drugs are going
to walk around narcan in their pocket
and feel like they can do it and
interesting the thing that we discovered
as we explored where we brought in
several people who are regular users
and their answer almost unanimously was
i thought i had that under control i'd
never think of bringing that narcan and
that was never anything that ever
crossed my mind
and
i think this and even the ambulance
drivers who responded and often the ones
that administered it wandering our way
to a question mark
would you would you i didn't hear you i
apologize
that's but i think and he's shaking his
head in such a way that i think he does
and i rest my case
thank you representative
sing no further questions thank you
senator
and the chair recognizes ryan fowler
from the new hampshire
providers association and you can tell
us what that is
what is the new hampshire providers
association so the new hampshire
products association is a membership
organization of substance use disorder
uh
providers in treatment prevention and
recovery okay
so across the continuum we represent
substance use professionals look at that
it's right there in the masthead of your
stationary indeed thank you thank you
thank you chairman and thank you to the
committee for hearing me
there is a letter going around from nhpa
um
as you've heard i'm ryan fowler i'm the
harm reduction coordinator for a small
aid service organization in lebanon new
hampshire
i work as a the harm reduction
coordinator in the upper valley of new
hampshire and vermont primarily my
full-time gig is operating a certain
services program that was made legal by
senate bill 234 a few years ago
um i'm also the policy chair for new
hampshire new hampshire providers
association i sit on the governor's
opioid task force i work with
the new hampshire training institute for
addiction professionals to hannica i
work for jsi as a consultant and advisor
and i'm here today in support of senate
bill 279 as kind of a pragmatic approach
forward with harm reduction in new
hampshire
i'm somebody who's alive because of harm
reduction i'm a former injection drug
user and i've been saved three times by
narcan i was provided syringes illegally
through my chaotic drug use i ended in
2014 and uh i come from a social circle
of people who are here because of harm
reduction you know harm reduction is a
as a strategy is really uh a way to keep
people alive because dead people don't
enter recovery and really recovery is a
natural thing when human needs are met
and for me the goal of a harm reduction
program is to meet human needs and
understand that people are using drugs
for no reason like any human behavior
serves a purpose including chaotic drug
use and what i see working primarily in
the claremont and lebanon region of new
hampshire and on the other side of the
river in vermont is that people are
meeting their human needs by using drugs
in a chaotic way and once we meet them
where they're at and empower them and
support them recovery is natural and i
see a far more recovery oriented
pathways than i do chaos i see a lot
more success stories and i hear death
stories because harm reduction works and
what we know is you know syringe
programs like the ones that i'm able to
operate in my region of new hampshire
they're possibly the most studied public
health intervention there's 30 plus
years of research that show that they're
a good idea but there's a lot of gaps in
new hampshire there's currently no
syringe access in laconia or the north
country and there's a
there's there is a significant cost
savings and return on investment when we
look at harm reduction as a way to
prevent health care costs death disease
transmission and it's just really really
unfortunate when people's needs aren't
met what happens to that chaotic drug
use that we see on the headlines time
and time again and you know as we look
at this as a public health issue we
realize that you know prohibition and
the war on drugs doesn't work really law
enforcement have no no business dealing
with a non-violent health issue so what
are we going to do when we address this
as a public health issue harm reduction
is a way to keep people alive and keep
people safe and save money and i think
that overdose prevention programs like
the one in the title of this bill are a
great idea but there's an order of
operations because harm reduction
strategies are on a continuum we heard
about narcan or naloxone we've heard
about syringe programs there are gaps in
new hampshire that i think that we're
going to find and if we invest money in
a way that supports people and doesn't
criminalize them or punish them then the
cost savings are really tremendous and
it really improves the quality of life
for everybody in the community what we
see when we empower people and meet
their human needs is that people get
better and they stop doing crime uh
think of this as pre-recovery engagement
and really it seems counterintuitive i
know it really does seem
counterintuitive because we only know
punitive responses in the war on drugs
we have to punish them but it doesn't
work it actually makes the problem a lot
worse you know we really need to see
um
something better we all need to do
something better about the drug problem
because putting people in a cage for a
health issue isn't an effective strategy
for producing trauma-related drug use
it's really built on trauma and it's
really um
that's my spiel you know i really
believe in this stuff i've dedicated a
lot of my life to it because
it works and it's just it's awesome to
see but is it working in new hampshire
you know there's currently several
programs mostly on the southern side of
the state you know where is it that we
can do better and i think that if we're
going to do anything to address this
problem harm reduction is the way to go
and my hope is that a study committee
will demonstrate that and allocate funds
accordingly thank you very much
representative webber with a question
i just note that your um letter here uh
says you're attaching a three-page fax
sheet and i didn't see that
so i wondered if you would be willing if
there is a such a fact sheet to just
email it to members of the committee so
that we could take a look at it
absolutely thank you i know that it was
emailed to senator waters i can
certainly make sure it's forwarded to
the committee
perfect thank you
senator representative nadarapam
um i wondered if you could supply your
contact information because i have like
a ton of questions that i won't take up
the committees with time today
absolutely okay thank you
and any other questions
saying none thank you so much and uh
welcome back the honorable joe hannon
i tell you
they always come back to us
thank you mr chairman i almost expected
your music after you said that
you didn't hear the music
never mind
um my name is joe hannon um and i'm in
support of um the support of this bill
uh a little background i am a person in
long term recovery over 30 years myself
i was as a representative i was a
co-sponsor of the naloxone the narcan
bill i had a lot of experience getting
that through the legislature which i can
tell you as you know was not easy
because of some of the rumors and
misconceptions out there i was also i
put in the first syringe exchange
legislation when i was in office and
then when i was out of office i had uh
our good senator here and another
senator be the prime sponsors for a new
bill which became law and now we have
certain service programs throughout most
of the state as uh ryan fowler said not
enough of it but um we've increased in a
very significant rate
um
one thing that we know and you've heard
this before there is over 30 years of
data that supports syringe service
programs and the effect they've had
narcan has been naloxone is a
life-saving drug that is absolutely
vital
and is the only thing that can actually
stop someone from overdosing when they
are overdosing from an opioid
um
you know we've heard one person already
here today say that they've been revived
three times um one of the negative
things you usually hear is people say oh
you know we this person was narcan 15
times
and you know why are we doing it again
people like
the person behind me and other people i
know friends of mine are here today
because we didn't give up on someone
um
when pushing for the syringe exchange
legislation i would talk to i talked to
everybody if anyone was here when i did
that you probably were sick of seeing me
but
i can tell you that i he's not thank you
um i i didn't start the conversation
with people who aren't familiar with
what syringe exchanges and other harm
reduction programs did by saying oh look
we're gonna help people who use drugs to
do it safely they're looking at me like
i'm crazy
but if i said look we've got this great
program that can is proven to save lives
and prevent infections hiv hepatitis c
prevent uh
you know the negative consequences of
all those actions and also as a way to
get people to have greater access to
recovery services and to help that they
need other medical services that they
they need and don't usually have that
gateway to because they're afraid to go
to hospitals because the way they're
treated they are usually uh and you know
though we do have some programs in the
in the penal system in the state
they are not enough
and they don't generally uh
get all the people that we need to have
treated many people are in jail because
of substance use and other mental health
issues and it's not the priority of the
penal system to get people
physically better into recovery even
though we have to provide treatment by
law that's not generally what happens
um you know we we've i don't want to get
too uh
grandiose here but like we've i heard
one person say you know do we have any
opioid prevention programs in new
hampshire and the answer is obviously no
there are very few in the united states
one recently opened up in new york city
we've got 100 over 160 some programs
around the world and one they all have
one thing in common no one has ever died
of an overdose in any of those
facilities we've had over a hundred
thousand people overdose in united
states in the last year and about almost
around two thirds of those died from an
opioid overdose
that number is not going down any law we
put in to increase penalties and arrest
people and try to take the drugs off the
street is not working drugs are stronger
cheaper and more potent and more people
are dying if we went to the state uh
stores and tried to buy a six-pack of
beer and one of out of those six beers
was a different concentration the beer
could probably kill you we'd all be kind
of nervous
you know
um
but back to the question do we have
opioid overdose prevention
centers in new hampshire sort of we have
bars
you know you go to a bar the bartender
cuts you off if you look like you're
getting too
inebriated someone might call you a ride
there's someone watching you most people
that overdose
overdose in the presence of someone else
most people that are found dead from an
overdose are found alone
and that's why we pass the good
samaritan law which allows people to
call during an overdose and that does
prevent that we don't have hard data on
it because we are a small state but we
do know that that is one thing that gets
people to get
the help that they need
uh we've heard i heard many stories from
paramedics and i that i know personally
and my wife has worked with his doctor
that people would be found in the shower
when they get called for an overdose
because they thought maybe the cold
water wake them up and they find out how
long they've been there 20 minutes they
might already be dead by then or have
brain damage
places where someone can go and get the
help get the supervision they need can
save their lives
you know and i
the the last thing i'll say is you know
on the way over thinking about this i
was thinking about the the parable the
good samaritan don't worry this isn't a
religious lecture just
the
the first person was that came upon him
just walked past the second person same
thing the third person actually helped
bandage the wounds and take care of that
person i think we're all called to be
that that good samaritan and this is a
great first step to starting that
process and to do it right by not just
leaving it to all the people that are
studying it i'm on the opioid task force
and lots of other meeting groups and
commissions
people are looking at this but we need
legislators to look at it to start the
process of getting you and everyone in
this building across the street to start
seriously contemplating how it's going
to work we know it works
we have to start thinking about how
we're going to do it and i think this is
the best first step to start and i'd be
happy to take any questions and thank
you for your time thank you
representative any questions
representative soloway
thank you mr chairman
uh thank you representative i haven't
seen you in a while it's been at least
48 hours i know
um can you describe any programs that
may exist or have existed in the dover
and rochester area that have been
effective
but you should mention that yeah um not
just
we didn't talk about this at breakfast
the other day um
the um we have syringe service programs
in rochester dover somersworth uh
there's there are programs now in
concord that has been started in the
last year we have a service program in
manchester they're also in uh the south
southern part of the state and west's
part of the state claremont
we don't have a lot in laconia in the
north country like you heard but there
are programs in manchester when we
started doing the sermon service program
there
the first
i think the first big month that we we
started in april or march i think i
forget the exact month but
uh a year later in may we gave out 500
kids of naloxone to people on the street
and many of them had report we keep an
eye we ask people you know we find out
how many syringes they give give us
guess we get how many we get back we
write it all down how many referrals we
make and another thing we ask people is
um
if you know have you reversed any
overdoses since the last time you were
here
in the first year and a half that that
program was in manchester our
participants reported over 3 000
overdoses were reversed that was more
than all the hospitals and paramedics in
the city combined not putting them down
at all they do a great job
but one thing we've seen in the data
from the state is
people even when paramedics are
responding to an overdose it is becoming
increasingly more common for them to
show up and someone has already received
narcan and is maybe already breathing
that is key so it's not just a matter of
making a phone call and sending someone
out to save a life we can have a program
where someone can be there and it's
almost instantaneous
um this is basically making it making
our job easier
most people that are using drugs
chaotically illicit substances on the
street are doing so
secretively they're trying to hide they
don't want to get caught they're doing
it as quickly as they can in a place
that may not be you know it may be in
public it may be
you know and it can create a public
health
risk when people are doing that not that
they're leaving syringes around more
more often they're actually less likely
to leave them around because of syringe
programs
but when someone is rushing and if
someone is not doing it in a clean
sanitary manner they're more likely to
get infections they're more likely to
overdose and die because they're doing
it very quickly when we teach people
that i when i we give out syringes to
people that are using iv substances we
teach them how to inject properly and
again some people might think oh you're
encouraging drug use you're you know
enabling it
we're only enabling people to not die
and not get sick or injured that's it
they're doing it anyway they were doing
it before we came along and they're
probably going to do it if this program
if all these programs go away but
the sicknesses will still be there in
higher numbers um the overdose numbers
that we've seen in this cut this state i
can't remember the exact number but it
was the year two years ago a year and a
half ago the very beginning of covid
uh overdose rates around the country had
increased drastically in just about
every state there were only i think two
states that they decreased in new
hampshire was one of them and that was
the year that we had a vast amount of
syringe service programs flooding the
areas with naloxone to not just
everybody but the end user the person
who was more likely to be around someone
that was going to see someone
overdosing and representative thank you
so much
for some other yeah because we the title
of the bill is do we establish a study
committee i thought we were doing it
studying it now
no yeah
we have an executive bill yeah all right
i'll wait all right
i really have missed you you know that
come back again don't be strange
any other questions
that's a good idea okay
thank you for coming thank you very much
this concludes the
uh hearing on senate bill 279.
wonder if we're ready to go to an exec
session or do you want to ponder it for
thank you
uh ponder it for a while what is what's
your pleasure
i'm sorry
we're getting thumbs up okay thumbs up
we're ready to rock and roll here okay
um open the exec session now on senate
bill uh 279 the chair will
entertain a motion
representative nada upham
again
um i move we ought to pass
otp
and who is that dr soloway dr soloway i
presume okay
i know
any discussion
doesn't have to be a question now this
is executing representative merchant
thank you um
like yourself i think we have a lot of
study committees and commissions and so
forth we have a hard time to fill them
however given the gravity of the
situation
i think we need to find a solution
because i mentioned before
on the prescription drug monitoring
program we've done a phenomenal job in
reducing the number of
illicit prescriptions or prescription
drugs being used illicitly
unfortunately did not tackle the
underlying problem which is addiction
and i think we need to find some way to
start looking at that seriously and find
some solutions to it
to me the idea well there's two things
the idea that uh
once this is signed into law it's got to
do a lot of work and be done by november
1st sounds to me like it's just a prep
group
for bill writing
and number two since the senators
promised me he will get the people to
fill the slots
i'm very happy so just a couple of
reasons one of the things i'll talk to
the senator afterwards is there is
sorry there on the advisory council
there's currently two reps and one
senator so i mean he could probably call
upon them as well and have some
cross-pollination between the two sounds
like a plan anyone else
share
ask
all right which which one of your group
has gone oh wow okay
um
the motion before us it's on senate bill
uh which
well you know you just heard it
establishing a study committee on harm
reduction and overdose prevention
programs the motion is ought to pass
made by representative nutter upham and
seconded by representative soloway would
the clerk please call the rule
representative leon yes
representative mcmahon yes
representative acton yes representative
gay
representative cushman
no
representative folsom yes
representative kelsey yes
representative king
yes
representative cofoult
representative delemus sorry
representative weber
representative mckay
representative snow yes representative
kanark yes representative soloway yeah
representative cannon yes representative
nutteruppum yes representative shapiro
yes representative woods yes
representative merchant
yes
representative pearson sorry yes
okay
19-1
and um
the committee report to be written by
representative nader oppam sure of
course can i move to put it on consent
no objection without objection no
objection no objection alrighty on
consent
this concludes the exec session on 279
and it looks like the amendment that we
spoke of this morning is back so um
representative merchants
well he'll tell us
279 you say
289.
yeah 270 now we just did
thanks
right
you want to speak to
two two nine
we're also looking for an amendment on
289.
this is this is 229. sorry
i i've
pinged ols once more
but the one that was more complicated
came back sooner than the one that was
thank you
that was the one
that was the one in which we had a
change because of drafting error in the
first paragraph
and the other one was the same time was
take the amendment that i created with
representative guthrie to add it to the
same amendment so we have one amendment
so you should have before you i want to
say thank you
no sorry
senate bill 229 the
chair
asks representative merchant please to
continue sir
thank you sir
i want to say thank you to represent
cushman to uh
working over this working with me on
this over lunch um and put our heads
together i think we came up with
something we all can agree we at least
agree with hopefully folks will agree
with us as well
so i gave out two pieces of paper one's
the amendment the other one's in 318 16
f because that's the part that's getting
repealed
and some of the concerns that were
shared were dealing with what was in 16
f because being repealed we lose it
and
in talking with representative
cushman i recognize that some of the
things that
she's referring to and the statue were
actually addressed in the rules but she
felt more comfortable and okay with it
putting in the statute
so what we did basically
oh yeah
um
did they get caught somewhere
i have
just one
you have a bunch of them
so
you should be looking up in front of you
to amendment two zero two two
one three three four h
and also you have another piece of paper
which is circulating which was section
three eighteen sixteen f which is the
statute itself
dealing with what's being repealed
and the reason i'm sharing this with you
is understanding what do you have them
both
which one
i do
so does everyone have
rsa 318 16f
and amendment 2022 1334h
okay
so
in talking with representative cushman
over lunch
the concern she had was
the fact that many things that are in
the rsa were actually in rules by the
board of pharmacy at the time we created
the
rules we recognized that one of the
things critical here is having whoever's
going to the vaccines
is being trained in cpr cardio pulmonary
resuscitation which is critical it's in
rules but it wasn't a statute so
basically we did if you look at
rsa31816f
and look at number six
certified pharmacy technician has a
current
certification of basic cardiopulmonary
recession station we've moved it from
this section
back into the amendment so it stays
consistent
the nice thing about it is because it's
in the statute now all the pharmacists
as well as the licensed technician and
the certified tech all have to be cpr
trained and we want that anyway no we we
do oh you want it okay i i wanted it but
i do
then we talked about in line 17
is no reference back to the statute
dealing with a certified registered
technician so to be consistent
we wanted to anchor it down in that rsa
which is rsa 318 15 a which is my
initial amendment
it's sort of implied but
we want to be sure it's explicit if you
look at line 20
2 through 24
is that the training has to include
hands-on
it can be something to take online
it's pretty hard to understand how to
give an injection online
so you want to be sure be clear that it
has to have
in person training
we also want to be sure that if you look
at number four which is line 25 buck
certification cardio pulmonary
resuscitation
because we added number four we had to
modify line 26
to include lines one through four
and the other requirement was the fact
which again is pretty
self-explanatory is that before you go
vaccine you should at least review the
vaccine registry
it's pretty much
implied but we wanted to make it
explicit so we did
i want to say thank you to
representative cushman for helping me
along the way and thank you very much
for working with me
representative merchant would you make a
motion on the amendment
i'll make a motion on the amendment to
pass amendment
two one three three four h
and representative cushman i will second
thank you
any further discussion
we have before us the amendment
2022-13-34
motion is ought to pass
made by representative merchant moved by
representative merchant and seconded by
representative cushman
and would the clerk please call the roll
representative leon yes
representative mcmahon
representative acton yes representative
gay
representative not here okay
representative cushman yes
representative folsom
representative kelsey yes
representative king yes
representative cofolt
not here representative lemus
representative weber
representative mckay
representative snow
representative canark yes
representative soloway
uh representative cannon yeah
representative nadarepam
representative shapiro yes
representative woods yes representative
merchant yes
and representative pearson
yes
sorry again
so that is rookies
uh 19
to two well two not voting no three not
voting
eighteen sorry yup you're right eighteen
to zero zero zero
three non-voting
now
you would like to make the motion for
the bill as amended
rep i was going to put you down anyway
representative cushman what is your
motion thank you mr chairman i'm mo i
move that we um
pass the house bill 229 as amended by
amendment 2022 1 3 3 4 h your motion is
out of pass is amended i will second
that representative cushman and seconded
by representative merchant any further
discussion
then would the clerk please call the
roll
representative leon yes representative
mcmahon
representative acton
representative gay is not voting
representative cushman
yes representative folsom yes
representative kelsey yes representative
king
yes representative cofoult
not voting
representative delemus
representative weber
representative mckay representative snow
representative canark yes representative
soloway
representative cannon
representative nadarepam
representative shapiro yes
representative woods yes representative
merchant
yes
representative pearson yes
all right we have 19.
19 to 0. sorry
consent and representative cushman if
you would write the committee report
please and if we can hang on about three
or four minutes
we've got the other amendment com being
run up from downstairs
does she have it upstairs
or she's making coffee sports okay
i think 289 i think it's 289 yeah
well
right now number 414.
here it is right there
is canark nice seconds
yes
i brought them all because i printed
them out at home last week and i was
ready to rock and roll here
laughs
opened
what was that about my dear brother
i would be honored to be in the same
paragraph as my friend
open the uh
i don't know what executive session on
the amendment to
sb 289 the chair rules at germain
and representative merchant would you
speak to the amendment
how it fulfills what we wanted thank you
mr chairman
and fellow members of the committee
um you should be looking at
amendment
two two
one three three six h
and the amendment is to house sorry
senate bill two eight nine
which was the glucagon administration
um and thank you representative kenner
for catching the typo
in line eight it now agrees with line
nine
it's amendment should be two zero two
two thirteen thirty six
all
right are we all set
oh thank you snow
so basically um represent canark
caught a
drafting error which was in line eight
we fixed that so line eight now agrees
with line 9
and we also then took the
amendment which i drafted earlier
to then include that language into this
amendment as well
which is
basically taking the format of the
prescription which is line 13
and moving it from what was attached
before in 318b over to our belongs now
which is 126 a 91.
it's a simple bill
we will keep it called such
and so are you moving this amendment i
will make a motion to move the amendment
and the chair seconds it
any further discussion on this
wonderful
little bitter
simple
seeing none hearing none um when you are
ready
rookie clerk call the roll
on
the amendment
motion is ought to pass
moved by
representative merchant and seconded by
the chair you may call the roll
representative leon yes representative
mcmahon
representative acton
representative gay
voting
representative cushman yes
representative folsom yes representative
kelsey yes
representative king
representative co fault
not here absent representative lemus
representative webster web sorry weber
absent
representative mckay
representative snow yes
representative kenner yes representative
soloway
representative cannon yes representative
nadareppum
representative shapiro
yes representative woods yes
representative merchant
yes
representative pearson yes
you're holding on to that rookie status
18-0
it's always fun when other people
realize that
calling that crazy list is probably the
hardest part of the job
representative merchant i call on you
for another motion i'll make a motion to
pass senate bill 289
with ought to pass with amendment and
the chair seconds it
and since the amendment we just
unanimously voted replaces the bill i
trust there's no further discussion
thank you
yeah
that's not
past our ability um
the motion before us is
house bill 28 not senate bill 289 as
amended by
amendment
2022-1336
motion out of pass as amended made by
representative merchant seconded by the
chair would the
trainee clerk please call the roll
thank you representative leon yes
representative mcmahon
representative acton
representative gay absent
representative cushman yes
representative folsom yes representative
kelsey yes representative king
representative cofoult
absent representative delemus
representative weber absent
representative mckay
representative snow yes representative
canark yes representative soloway
representative cannon yes representative
natarapam
representative shapiro yes
representative woods yes representative
merchant yes representative pearson
[Laughter]
yes 18-0 18-0 what do we remind the
chair of
consense and representative merchant to
write the committee report and this
concludes the exact session
on senate bill 289 and folks we got a
lot of work done today it went well i
think everybody had a chance to speak
when you needed to i want to thank
christina daya so much thank you for all
of this making it possible today
and because you did such a good job we
hope to see you again next tuesday 9 30.
remember it is the revised
schedule for next tuesday you'll be
seeing that in the house calendar coming
out in a few days
we will be looking at four
late
from the senate but early we must act
bills and they're
going to be some
differences of opinion
uh
miss dia are there copies available for
next tuesday's bill
and they were all in the packet today
so we're finished thank you everybody
good job all
you